We saw a ghost inside our house, a waltz of wishful thinking. Please send us a miracle so I know that there is meaning. Instead of think that it's a miracle just to be breathing. So live on, baby, live on. Just to be breathing so So We have one book about a duck and one book about a bear and one book Now about a ghost but all of them are about the dark and sad heart of the twisted animal That is man, Matt Hong Galtz Helling. Welcome back to the Taproot Therapy collective podcast excited Matt is the last journalist Hong-Golz Helling, welcome back to the Taproot Therapy collective podcast. Excited to get to your next book.
我们在屋里看到了鬼魂，那是一场一厢情愿的华尔兹。请赐予我们一个奇迹，好让我知道生命是有意义的，而不是仅仅认为活着本身就是一种奇迹。所以，宝贝，活下去，活下去。仅仅是活着，所以，所以，我们有一本关于鸭子的书，一本关于熊的书，现在还有一本关于鬼魂的书，但它们讲的都是那个扭曲的动物——人类——那颗黑暗而悲伤的心，马特·洪·加尔茨·赫林。欢迎回到 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客，很高兴马特是最后一位记者洪-戈尔茨·赫林，欢迎回到 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。很高兴能聊聊你的下一本书。
Matt is the last journalist working in America. How does it feel? Tell us about the before time. Oh, I left the field long ago. I'm not holding that bag. Well, we really enjoyed the Ghost Lab, which is, is that on sale now? When does it come out?
马特是美国最后一位还在工作的记者。感觉如何？给我们讲讲以前的时光吧。哦，我很久以前就离开那个领域了。我可不背那个锅。好吧，我们真的很喜欢《鬼魂实验室》，这本书现在在卖吗？什么时候出版？
It comes out on May 20th. Okay. Thank you so much. You're actually one of only a handful of people who have read it, Joel. I bet you not, you know, 40 people in the world have gotten their hands on an advanced copy.
它在5月20日出版。好的。非常感谢。乔尔，你其实是为数不多读过这本书的人之一。我敢说，世界上大概没几个人，也就40个人拿到过预读本。
So I'm so, so gratified that you received one and took the time to read it and have been kind enough to give me some good feedback on it. So I really appreciate that. I think you do a great job. And I'm hoping that we can have a conversation about kind of like your subject selection
所以我非常非常欣慰你能收到一本，并花时间阅读它，还很友好地给了我一些很好的反馈。我真的很感激。我觉得你做得很好。我希望我们能就你的选题和思考过程进行一番对话。
and thought process. You have a nuanced relationship to the subjects that's inherently kind of, I don't wanna say critical, but respectful and also inquiring that, that sits with a lot of stuff. But also, you know, you talk about your relationship to the subjects that they like the book, and, and then maybe a kind of a broader look at some of the things you suggest at the end that would improve our relationship to healthcare and institutions at a time where I think institutional credibility is really much on the decline in a way that, you know, whoever's fault it is,
你与研究对象之间有着一种微妙的关系，这种关系本质上是——我不想说是批判性的，但它是尊重的，同时也是探究性的，它能容纳很多东西。而且，你知道，你谈到了你与那些喜欢这本书的研究对象的关系，然后也许可以更广泛地审视一下你在书末提出的一些建议，这些建议旨在改善我们与医疗保健和机构的关系，而在我看来，机构的可信度确实在大幅下降，不管是谁的错，
it's still kind of a damaging thing that's not good. And you propose some interesting solutions and kind of sit with a lot of nuance there. So if you, we can start with that and kind of go through that, that'd be great. Yeah, thank you very much for noting that. And yeah, it was sort of like a weird headspace for me to get into because I am sort of personally like a skeptic. I'm one of these
这仍然是一种破坏性的事情，是不好的。你提出了一些有趣的解决方案，并在其中融入了许多细微的差别。所以，如果我们能从这里开始，并深入探讨一下，那就太好了。是的，非常感谢你注意到这一点。是的，这对我来说是一种奇怪的心境，因为我个人其实是一个怀疑论者。我是那种……
and I know you've written some really fascinating stuff about sort of like getting too married to quantifiable outcomes, right? Which doesn't mean it's not important. It's just, and I think that's two conversations too. Cause I mean, part of what I, my criticism is like, there's some things that should just be self evident in medicine that we should just let be self evident and not pretend like, Oh, well,
我知道你写过一些非常引人入胜的文章，关于那种过于执着于可量化结果的倾向，对吧？这并不是说它不重要。只是，我认为这也是两个不同的对话。因为我的部分批评是，医学中有些事情应该是显而易见的，我们应该让它们保持显而易见，而不是假装说，哦，好吧，
we need to research it because it threatens the profit motive. No, like, we know this stuff's real. Kind of go on and move on. And then secondly, I think psychology which is you know I'm doing therapy doesn't behave the same as cancer research in a way that we kind of pretend that it needs to Yeah, a lot of your like objective you looking at that stuff is really it was really fascinating And you know like you've got three books a libertarian walks into a bear if it walks like a quack and also libertarian walks into a bear, if it walks like a quack, and also the ghost lab now. And in all of them, you select a subject
我们需要研究它，因为它威胁到了利润动机。不，我们知道这些东西是真实的。继续前进吧。其次，我认为心理学——你知道我正在做治疗——其表现方式与癌症研究不同，而我们却假装它需要像癌症研究那样。是的，你观察这些事情的客观视角真的很迷人。你知道，你有三本书，《自由意志主义者走进熊的领地》、《如果它走起来像个骗子》，还有《鬼魂实验室》。在所有这些书中，你选择了一个
that is kind of like a microcosm for a bigger thing, but you don't opine a ton. I mean, the focus of it is investigative journalism. And like, you're looking at these people who we don't know, but we feel like we know, because they're relevant to a larger conversation that you're trying to talk about. So could you talk about the process of kind of like subject selection and, you know, because they're relevant to a larger conversation that you're trying to talk about. So could you talk about the process
作为更大事物缩影的主题，但你并没有发表太多意见。我的意思是，它的重点是调查新闻。而且，你关注的是那些我们不认识，但感觉上又认识的人，因为他们与你试图讨论的更宏大的对话相关。所以，你能谈谈选题的过程吗，因为他们与你试图讨论的更宏大的对话相关。所以，你能谈谈选题的过程吗？
of kind of like subject selection and, you know, what put you in that? Absolutely. Yeah. So, um, yeah, so I kind of started off wanting to write about the lack of trust that that is sort of like blooming in America, right? And, and, you know, you can say, Oh, yeah, well, that's because government sucks. And that's why there's declining trust in government. But then there's also decline in hospitals. Okay, well, our healthcare system sucks. Okay. Health is trust in science is also declining. Well, that's because you know, science, you know, at some
选题的过程，以及是什么让你进入这个领域的？绝对可以。是的，所以我开始时是想写关于美国正在滋生的那种信任缺失的问题，对吧？你可以说，哦，是的，那是因为政府太烂了，所以对政府的信任在下降。但医院的信任度也在下降。好吧，我们的医疗体系太烂了。好吧，对科学的信任也在下降。好吧，那是因为你知道，科学，在某个
point you start to say, like, are there something that's sort of tilting the playing field, right? Against trust. And people are trusting their neighbors less, people are trusting their churches less. People are just trusting everything less than they did as recently as 20 years ago, grammatically less. And so I was sort of like, looking at all this stuff and sort of casting about for reasons why this might be so. And what I found was that the trust in institutions, the ebb in that trust could be measured in people who were sort of opting out of some of these societal institutional systems that we've had in place for so long. Right?
点上你开始说，是不是有什么东西在倾斜竞争环境，对吧？反对信任。人们越来越不信任邻居，越来越不信任教堂。人们对一切事物的信任度都比20年前低，确实如此。所以我一直在观察所有这些事情，并寻找原因。我发现，对机构的信任，这种信任的减退，可以在那些选择退出我们长期以来建立的某些社会机构系统的人身上衡量出来。对吧？
So, so, and you know, to speak a little bit to your field, there's a segment of people who are saying, I can't trust the branch of psychology. I also can't trust, you know, therapy. Yeah. My worldview is, puts me in a place where that is all sus, right? And so they are turning to sort of other avenues. So I was like, okay, well, who's sort of inheriting that trust that institutions are losing. And what I found is that people are taking their problems of various sorts that used to be solved by institutions
所以，说到你的领域，有一部分人说，我不能信任心理学分支。我也不能信任，你知道，治疗。是的，我的世界观让我觉得这一切都很可疑，对吧？所以他们正在转向其他途径。所以我当时想，好吧，谁在继承机构失去的那些信任呢？我发现人们正在把他们过去由机构解决的各种问题，
or at least in the sort of like the golden age of institutions the last 80 years or so, and instead are putting their trust in the paranormal believer community, right? So they are So anyhow So as soon as I kind of like cotton to the the paranormal thing that folks are seeking Services from you know, alien abduction support groups appear groups That people are seeking support from their mediums and psychics. People are looking for
或者至少在过去80年左右的机构黄金时代，转而将信任寄托在超自然信仰者群体身上，对吧？所以他们是……总之，一旦我开始接触人们寻求服务的超自然事物，比如外星人绑架支持小组，人们寻求灵媒和通灵者的支持。人们正在寻找
explanations for their feelings of unease from ghost hunters and so on. And they're looking for their answers in these other places. And so then I really wanted to find a sort of representative group of these sorts of, you know, industry is probably too strong a word, but these sorts of communities and belief systems. And I landed on a really interesting, small, colorful group of folks in New Hampshire's seacoast region who, you know, among them, you know, there were five or six principal players, and they were like, yeah, there's a ghost hunter. There was an alien abductee who was also a big foot hunter. There was an empath. There was a psychic medium and so on. And so they, they just really reflected sort of like the spectrum of beliefs that
从捉鬼人那里寻找不安感的解释，等等。他们正在这些地方寻找答案。所以我真的很想找到一类具有代表性的这类——行业这个词可能太强了——这类社区和信仰体系。我最终在新罕布什尔州海岸地区找到了一群非常有趣、色彩鲜明的人，你知道，其中有五六个主要人物，他们就像，是的，有一个捉鬼人。有一个外星人被绑架者，他也是个大脚怪猎人。有一个共情者。有一个灵媒等等。所以他们真的反映了那种信仰的谱系，
are united under the broader umbrella of paranormal beliefs. And so I, I spent a couple of years, you know, talking to these folks. Um, and when I said earlier that it put me into a weird headspace, um, you know, I'm, I'm the numbers guy, right? I am, uh, you know, my, my wife sent me a video, uh, yesterday that said, this makes me sad. And the video was of kids running like a school shooting drill in school. Right.
在超自然信仰的更广泛保护伞下统一起来。所以我花了几年时间，你知道，和这些人交谈。当我刚才说这让我进入了一种奇怪的心境时，你知道，我是个数字控，对吧？我是，你知道，我妻子昨天给我发了一个视频，说这让我很难过。视频里是孩子们在学校进行校园枪击演习。对吧。
And my wife's a teacher. So, you know, I'm a social worker, married to a teacher. So we're very much like in the world of watching the decline of these institutions that are, you know, public institutions and you privatize them. I don't know what our role is or what our thing is. And, um, when you look at, um, yeah, the effects that the decline of this stuff, Yeah, the effects that the decline of this stuff has. I mean, my wife had like when she was trained, the cops go through and they shoot like huge assault rifles
我妻子是老师。所以，你知道，我是一个嫁给老师的社会工作者。所以我们非常身处观察这些机构衰落的世界中，这些机构是，你知道，公共机构，而你把它们私有化了。我不知道我们的角色是什么，或者我们的事情是什么。而且，当你观察，嗯，是的，这些东西衰落的影响，是的，这些东西衰落的影响。我的意思是，我妻子在接受培训时，警察走进来，拿着巨大的突击步枪，
and show you the noise and all this stuff. And it's like, that's a school training is horrifying. Yeah, and I think when my wife said that to me, I thought like, is this really necessary? Because clearly this has some downsides. And so then, so for me, for my math brain, I'm like, okay, what's the quantifiable risk? Like what are the odds that a child will be killed
展示噪音和所有这些东西。这就像，那是一场学校培训，太可怕了。是的，我想当我妻子对我那样说时，我想，这真的有必要吗？因为这显然有一些负面影响。所以，对于我的数学大脑来说，我在想，好吧，可量化的风险是什么？孩子在校园枪击案中被杀的几率是多少？
in a school shooting? It's like one in a million. And when I'm thinking about safety for my own children, my ears really start to perk up around the one in 10,000 mark, right? Like risks that are significantly greater than one in 10,000, I am very attuned to. But if I find that a risk is much less than one in 10,000, if it's one in 100,000, you know, I start to think like, you know, possibly the barriers that we put up to protect that child from that risk are themselves creating more harm than they are they are worth.
大概是百万分之一。当我在考虑我自己的孩子的安全时，我的耳朵真的开始在万分之一这个标记附近竖起来了，对吧？比如风险显著高于万分之一的，我非常关注。但如果我发现风险远低于万分之一，如果是十万分之一，你知道，我开始想，你知道，我们为了保护孩子免受这种风险而设置的障碍本身可能造成的伤害比它们本身的价值更大。
I'm thinking of like, during a lot of the like Bush years terrorism scare, you know, they would compare your risk of dying of a heart attack with like your risk of being killed by a terrorist or something. And, you know, people are like eating the Baconator and then, you know, people are like eating the Baconator and then, you know, protect me from Al Qaeda. And I'm more of kind of like, what is the most likely outcome? You know, not, how do I keep my emotions out of this and look at like, what is actually likely to be the threat to public health? And, you know, I don't know that it is 9-11, you know? Yeah, yeah. I, I agree entirely. Yeah. Like we, we, we've, um, uh, changed a lot of've changed a lot of systems, right? In response to 9-11, and it's not at all clear that those systems truly keep us safe.
我想到的是，在布什政府时期的恐怖主义恐慌期间，你知道，他们会把你死于心脏病的风险与你被恐怖分子杀害的风险进行比较。人们就像在吃培根汉堡，然后，你知道，人们说保护我免受基地组织的伤害。我更倾向于，最可能的结果是什么？你知道，不是，我如何把我的情绪排除在外，看看什么才是真正可能对公共健康构成的威胁？而且，你知道，我不知道那是不是9-11，你知道？是的，我完全同意。是的。就像我们，嗯，改变了很多系统，对吧？为了应对9-11，而且这些系统是否真正保护了我们的安全，这一点根本不清楚。
And it seems like there are many other disadvantageous aspects to those changes. It's a very sort of like reactionary position that we would never build from the ground up if we were building our society from scratch. Yeah, when you're inherently reactionary and you can never really have a vision of the future, which I think is where we are now, you your own, you're you don't, there's no plan for where you end up. Like everything is like, yeah, I mean, we're kind of here because this happened 10 years ago and then we did that.
而且似乎这些变化还有许多其他不利方面。这是一种非常反动的立场，如果我们从零开始建设我们的社会，我们永远不会从头开始建立它。是的，当你本质上是反动的，你永远无法真正拥有对未来的愿景，我认为我们现在就是这样，你自己的，你没有，没有计划你最终会去哪里。就像一切都是，是的，我的意思是，我们之所以在这里是因为10年前发生了这件事，然后我们做了那个。
And it's like, yeah, but why are we doing all of this together? Like why can we have like a, can we admit the things that don't work, don't work? And I think like a lot of your book is pretty bipartisan in the issues it talks about, you know, liberals are more likely to cling to institutions. But I mean, I think some of these institutions have lost credibility for a reason that has to be solved if you want credibility to come back.
就像，是的，但为什么我们要一起做所有这些？就像为什么我们不能，我们能承认那些不起作用的事情就是不起作用吗？我认为你的书在它讨论的问题上是相当两党制的，你知道，自由派更倾向于坚持机构。但我的意思是，我认为其中一些机构失去可信度是有原因的，如果你想让可信度回归，就必须解决这个问题。
And the kind of blind fate thing of vote blue no matter who or whatever when you're not really being offered a solution is just not an answer, any more than the kind of right-wing reactionary grievance stuff that, you know, it changes every, you know, the enemy changes every two years and a lot of what you talk about is is like It contains the the the respectful seed of like a greater Vision, you know for society which is you know, it's a book about a ghost lab. It's a book about paranormal researchers I mean even like when I'm getting to like you talking about the flock of dodo stuff with the threat to Science that was predicted predicted you know decades back when people kind of saw this stuff I'm like yeah I'm like
那种盲目的命运，比如无论谁当选都要投蓝色，或者当你没有真正被提供解决方案时，那根本不是答案，就像那种右翼反动的委屈一样，你知道，敌人每两年换一次，而你谈论的很多东西就像它包含了某种更伟大愿景的尊重种子，你知道，为了社会，你知道，这是一本关于鬼魂实验室的书。这是一本关于超自然研究者的书，我的意思是，即使当我谈到你谈论的关于科学威胁的渡渡鸟群的东西，那是几十年前预测的，当人们看到这些东西时，我心想，是的，我心想
really admiring how all these threads come together and like where you go where you go because you know it doesn't leave it doesn't jump topics but it pretty naturally just contains a lot of creativity and insight. I'm really grateful to hear you say that and to hear that some of those aspects are landing with at least one reader. Now, if I can just scale that up, I'll be a very happy man. And yeah, no, you're absolutely correct. Political partisanship drives people into forms of dogmatic expressions that are really unhelpful.
真的很钦佩所有这些线索是如何汇集在一起的，以及你走向哪里，因为你知道，它没有离开，它没有跳跃话题，但它非常自然地包含了大量的创造力和洞察力。听到你这么说，听到其中一些方面至少能引起一位读者的共鸣，我真的非常感激。现在，如果我能把它扩大规模，我将是一个非常快乐的人。是的，不，你是完全正确的。政治党派偏见驱使人们进入那种毫无帮助的教条式表达。
And when I was approaching the book and the paranormal, I was a diehard skeptic. As I said, I'm a numbers guy. And I want this. If the guys in I'm a numbers guy and I want this, if the guys in the white coats don't say it's true, I am very, very leery to say that's true. And I sort of like went in with this attitude that all of this stuff is BS, right? But I also sort of knew that I had to respect the worldview of the folks that I was speaking to because as I told them early in the process, you're not criminals, you're not politicians
当我接近这本书和超自然现象时，我是一个死硬的怀疑论者。正如我所说，我是个数字控。我想要这个。如果穿白大褂的人不说它是真的，我非常非常怀疑那是真的。我带着这种态度进去，认为所有这些东西都是胡扯，对吧？但我也知道我必须尊重我所交谈的人的世界观，因为正如我在过程早期告诉他们的，你们不是罪犯，你们不是政客，
who are being held up for transparency and public inspection. You are someone with what to me amounts to sort of an interesting hobby or pastime. And so the fact that they were willing to speak with me reflected a certain amount of trust on their part. And I really wanted to sort of honor that. And that sort of led me into building relationships with these people and their worldviews that really made me sort of appreciate that while I remain skeptical, I don't necessarily think that shifts to what
因为透明度和公众监督而被扣留。你是一个拥有对我来说相当于一种有趣的爱好或消遣的人。所以他们愿意与我交谈的事实反映了他们一定程度的信任。我真的想尊重这一点。这引导我与这些人及其世界观建立了关系，这真的让我意识到，虽然我仍然持怀疑态度，但我并不一定认为这种转变到
I call in the book a post-institutional world have to be bad outcomes. You know, we can have weaker institutions. Psychics can provide some of these services, but, you know, we have to build a bridge to get there if that's where we're deciding to go. We can't debunk ghosts out of existence. It's a belief that goes back to the Bronze Age. You know, I don't know that you're going to get your religion in that way. I think you have to reconcile with it. I'm a Jungian leading therapist and I think the transcendent function is pretty inherent
我书中所说的后机构世界必须是坏结果。你知道，我们可以有更弱的机构。灵媒可以提供其中一些服务，但是，你知道，如果我们决定去那里，我们必须架起一座桥梁才能到达那里。我们不能把鬼魂从存在中抹去。这是一种可以追溯到青铜时代的信仰。你知道，我不认为你会以那种方式获得你的宗教。我认为你必须与它和解。我是一名荣格派治疗师，我认为超越功能是相当内在的，
in how we make meaning and that we kind of create a cosmology. It maybe is healthier to engage with that in a symbolic or a metaphorical way. But I don't know that everyone always will. And, you know, if a patient came into therapy or to the doctor and they were a religion that the provider is not, you know, you wouldn't just discount everything and try. I mean, it's built into the code of ethics now that you have to take these religious beliefs seriously. That doesn't mean that you have to take them literally, or you have to recommend behavior that's destructive. I mean, you point out where that isn't helpful, or where there's an abuse of power structure that somebody's participating in, just because they believe in a God or gods that I
在我们如何创造意义以及我们创造宇宙观的方式中。以象征性或隐喻性的方式参与其中可能更健康。但我不知道每个人是否总是会这样。而且，你知道，如果一个病人来到治疗室或医生那里，他们信奉的宗教与提供者不同，你知道，你不会只是打折一切并尝试。我的意思是，现在的道德准则中已经内置了你必须认真对待这些宗教信仰。这并不意味着你必须字面理解它们，或者你必须推荐破坏性的行为。我的意思是，你指出了哪里没有帮助，或者哪里存在权力结构的滥用，有人参与其中，仅仅因为他们相信一个上帝或神，而我
don't, or a way of relating to that, or definition of any of that stuff. I mean to me. It's like why fight about these things anyway you know, I don't people have a metaphorical and a symbolic sense of Reality that that science and health care have to make room for in order to treat people because we don't treat them in a lab We don't treat them in a research study. We treat them in life Yeah, I bumped into a therapist just yesterday, sort of like on the playground, our kids were playing together. And I started sort of like talking to her and asking her about these things when I found out what her field was.
不相信，或者一种与之相关的方式，或对所有这些东西的定义。对我来说，为什么还要为这些事情争吵呢，你知道，我不认为人们有一种隐喻和象征性的现实感，科学和医疗保健必须为之留出空间，以便治疗人们，因为我们不在实验室里治疗他们。我们不在研究中治疗他们。我们在生活中治疗他们。是的，昨天我在操场上碰到了一个治疗师，我们的孩子在一起玩。当我发现她的领域是什么时，我开始和她交谈并问她这些事情。
And she said, oh, yes, you know, in our office, in our practice, which is focused on sort of like substance abuse and addiction issues. in our office, in our practice, which is focused on sort of like substance abuse and addiction issues. You know, we really are mindful not to challenge these delusions. And so like, I walked away from the conversation thinking like, Oh, isn't that great? She's not challenging the delusions. But then, you know, I think really well, where I've ultimately landed through the course of writing this book is that to even think of them as delusions is sort of like pejorative, right? It's a sort of patronizing position. Yeah. I think a lot of patients are going to smell and sort of like get away from going.
她说，哦，是的，你知道，在我们的办公室，在我们的实践中，专注于某种物质滥用和成瘾问题。在我们的办公室，在我们的实践中，专注于某种物质滥用和成瘾问题。你知道，我们真的注意不去挑战这些妄想。所以，我离开谈话时心想，哦，那不是很好吗？她没有挑战妄想。但是，你知道，我真的想，好吧，通过写这本书，我最终得出的结论是，甚至把它们视为妄想也是一种贬义，对吧？这是一种居高临下的立场。是的。我认为很多病人会闻到这种味道，并试图远离。
And you talked about the need to respect other other religions and I think that's absolutely true The folks that I focus on in the book are you know sort of like the 22% of Americans who are you know? Spiritual but not religious is how they they categorize. I think there's something there, but they don't think church has the answers and They are You know a lot of times those expressions are, you know, hey, I think that I've been abducted by an alien. And a therapist does not have the same training necessarily to sort of like get into that headspace in a way, it can't necessarily speak
你谈到了尊重其他宗教的必要性，我认为这是绝对正确的。我在书中关注的人是，你知道，大约22%的美国人，他们是，你知道，精神上但不是宗教上的，这是他们分类的方式。我认为那里有一些东西，但他们不认为教堂有答案，而且他们是，你知道，很多时候那些表达是，你知道，嘿，我认为我被外星人绑架了。而治疗师不一定有同样的训练来进入那种心境，它不一定能说
in a language that the purported alien abductee will respect and understand and feel heard in. Yeah. Well, and I started my career working with some of the worst cases of schizophrenia comorbid with other illnesses in the state. And a lot of those patients, so I mean, one, anti-psychotics don't treat delusion, they treat hallucinations. So the hallucinations can stop. But that doesn't mean that the belief goes away. A lot of times the delusion stays. And when you do that, I mean, the least effective social workers that I saw went in and were like, this isn't true. This can't be true. Here's all the reasons. And coming from this place of hostility that is debate
一种被声称的外星人绑架者会尊重、理解并感到被倾听的语言。是的。好吧，我职业生涯的开始是与该州一些最严重的精神分裂症合并其他疾病的病例一起工作。很多那些病人，所以我的意思是，第一，抗精神病药不治疗妄想，它们治疗幻觉。所以幻觉可以停止。但这并不意味着信仰消失了。很多时候妄想留下了。当你这样做时，我的意思是，我见过的最无效的社会工作者走进去说，这不是真的。这不可能是真的。这是所有的原因。而来自这种敌意的地方，就像辩论
club, like it's completely ineffective, I think, therapeutically or politically just getting lost in a debate about logic is the worst thing you can do. You follow emotion. I mean, same thing I do now. And the way that I was affected with people was, I'm not talking about the dragon that lives in your basement.
俱乐部，就像它完全无效，我认为，在治疗上或政治上，陷入关于逻辑的辩论是你所能做的最糟糕的事情。你跟随情绪。我的意思是，我现在做同样的事情。我与人有效的方式是，我不是在谈论住在你地下室的龙。
I'm gonna say, oh my God, you must be so scared. And I can see that your back is tired. I can see that you haven't eaten and you're just dealing with a lot of stress. And all of a sudden we're on the same page and we're talking about the dragon because the dragon is a metaphor for the sexual abuse that I experienced or whatever. I'm not going to have insight into this maybe in the way that I... I'm not going to have insight into this the way that you or I would, but I'm still treating this with respect and
我会说，哦，天哪，你一定很害怕。我能看出你的背很累。我能看出你没吃东西，你正在处理很多压力。突然之间，我们在同一页上，我们在谈论龙，因为龙是我经历的性虐待的隐喻，或者其他什么。我可能不会像你或我那样对这个有洞察力，但我仍然在尊重地对待这个，而且
it also has a symbolic truth even though I don't believe that there literally is a dragon in their basement. You know, I had somebody one time, a long time ago, and it was, you know, pretty classic paranoid schizophrenia before I ever, this is, this is when I first started my career. And I was like, you know, you used to say that you were getting this information from books or from these online communities or you're getting it on the internet. But now you are in your house and you have all the aluminum foil and the traps for the government and all this stuff.
它也有一种象征性的真理，尽管我不相信他们的地下室里真的有一条龙。你知道，很久以前，我曾经有一个人，那是，你知道，相当典型的偏执型精神分裂症，在我之前，这是，这是我刚开始职业生涯的时候。我说，你知道，你过去常说你从书本或这些在线社区获得这些信息，或者你在互联网上获得它。但现在你在你的房子里，你有所有的铝箔和政府的陷阱以及所有这些东西。
And there's no access information. Like you don't have internet anymore. You don't have books you don't leave. So how are you figuring out what the government is doing with these lasers and satellites to put the words in your head? And he said, that's a good question. You get the feeling that you have
而且没有访问信息。就像你不再有互联网了。你没有书，你不离开。那你怎么弄清楚政府正在用这些激光和卫星做什么来把话语放进你的脑子里？他说，那是个好问题。你得到那种感觉，
when you're wondering if something's true, but then you just know that it is. Which is a really amazing description of a delusion. Because the ability to reality test with a dopamine disorder like that, it's just not there. And fighting about that deficit is just kind of pointless. And you probably get somewhere interesting. I mean, you do get somewhere interesting with these people.
当你怀疑某事是否真实时，但随后你只是知道它是真的。这对于妄想来说是一个非常惊人的描述。因为用那种多巴胺紊乱进行现实测试的能力，它根本不存在。而为那种赤字争吵只是有点毫无意义。而且你可能会得到一些有趣的地方。我的意思是，你确实和这些人得到了一些有趣的地方。
Could you tell us? I mean, I don't want to spoil anything, but could you tell us about the major characters, how you met them, how they present, and then the ultimate disagreements that they have, or the differing conditions they had within their own community? Yeah, yeah. The book sort of like nicely sort of locked
你能告诉我们吗？我的意思是，我不想剧透任何东西，但你能告诉我们主要角色，你是怎么认识他们的，他们是如何呈现的，以及他们最终的分歧，或者他们在自己社区内拥有的不同条件？是的，是的。这本书有点像很好地锁定了
into this really fascinating sort of central narrative, where you had a guy named Andy Kitt, who is very much, he's a ghost hunter. He was motivated to sort of enter the field of ghost hunting from a strong personal experience that he had in the wake of his father's death, where he was kind of coming to terms with grief, almost. Yeah, coming to grieving, part of grieving. Absolutely. And you know, and he and his whole family sort of like experiences
这个非常迷人的中心叙事，你有一个叫安迪·基特的人，他非常，他是一个捉鬼人。他被激励进入捉鬼领域，是因为他在父亲去世后有强烈的个人经历，在那里他几乎是在接受悲伤。是的，接受悲伤，悲伤的一部分。绝对的。而且你知道，他和他的整个家庭有点像经历
had a set of experiences that they believed were indicative of their father speaking from beyond the grave. And Andy got into ghost hunting and he's by nature sort of like a combative conservative, you know, a crank for lack of a better word. He he wants proof for things and he is, you know, sort of like happy to offend and And he is sort of happy to offend and will not work nonsense. And so he sort of took this attitude into ghost hunting and essentially felt like most of the ghost hunters were jokes and most of the psychics were jokes.
了一系列他们认为表明父亲在坟墓外说话的经历。安迪进入了捉鬼领域，他天生有点像一个好斗的保守派，你知道，用一个更好的词来说就是一个怪人。他想要事物的证据，而且他，你知道，有点乐于冒犯，而且他乐于冒犯，不会做无意义的事情。所以他带着这种态度进入了捉鬼领域，本质上觉得大多数捉鬼人都是笑话，大多数灵媒都是笑话。
And so he started to experiment with it. He made for TV, so like reality TV that gives everybody a bad name. Yeah, reality TV that, you know, gives everybody a bad name. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He called him fluffy donuts, which was a term he seemed very comfortable with. I'd never heard it before I spoke to him, but it's evocative. So he he sort of like assembled this team that included Bo Esby, who was a psychic included Bo Esby, who was a psychic whose sort of like ability to communicate with spirits and at times foretell the future. Andy really found to be authentic and resonated with him.
所以他开始尝试它。他制作了电视节目，所以就像给每个人带来坏名声的真人秀。是的，真人秀，你知道，给每个人带来坏名声。是的，是的，是的，是的。他称他们为蓬松的甜甜圈，这是一个他似乎非常舒服的词。我在和他交谈之前从未听说过它，但它很生动。所以他有点像组建了这个团队，包括博·埃斯比，他是一个灵媒，包括博·埃斯比，他是一个灵媒，他的那种与灵魂交流的能力，有时预言未来。安迪真的发现是真实的，并与他产生了共鸣。
And they sort of picked up this guy, Mike Stevens, who was the alien abductee who made contact with them while trying to get petitions to honor a famous alien abduction site in the state of New Hampshire. He wanted recognition from the state, sort of like a state monument or historical marker there. And Mike is a very sort of traumatized guy by his alien abduction experiences, which have plagued him since childhood. And then they picked up a couple
他们有点像捡到了这个叫迈克·史蒂文斯的人，他是外星人被绑架者，在试图获得请愿书以纪念新罕布什尔州一个著名的外星人绑架地点时与他们取得了联系。他想要国家的认可，有点像那里的国家纪念碑或历史标记。迈克是一个被他的外星人绑架经历所伤害的人，这些经历从童年起就困扰着他。然后他们捡到了几个
of other central characters along the way, Val LoFaso, who is a psychic slash aspiring fiction writer, or I should say published fiction writer, and Ange Bourdages, but she, uh, sort of like primary, uh, primarily identifies with her, her job as a, a, uh, legal assistant. And yeah, so she's all about the paperwork and managing risk and that sort of stuff. And so they, they sort of like come together under this, this sort of noble shared dream of we're going to bring science to these fields and we're going
沿途的其他核心人物，瓦尔·洛法索，他是一个灵媒兼有抱负的小说家，或者我应该说已出版的小说家，还有安吉·布尔达热斯，但她，嗯，有点像主要，嗯，主要认同她，她的工作作为一名，一名，嗯，法律助理。而且是的，所以她全是关于文书工作和管理风险以及这类事情。所以他们，他们有点像聚集在这个，这个有点像高尚的共同梦想下，我们要把科学带到这些领域，我们要
to sort out the week from the chaff and we're going to bring science to these fields and we're going to sort out the wheat from the chaff and we're going to tell them they have systems of getting objective data that were in place. Yeah. They wanted to get it. Not just I saw this and wrote it down, but actually get quantified data of the supernatural essentially. Absolutely. Absolutely. And Andy him in particular was very sort of well-versed in what constitutes a blind study and those sorts of things. So Andy was the one who could spearhead drafting protocols that would maintain some integrity of their investigations and results.
把小麦从谷壳中分出来，我们要把科学带到这些领域，我们要把小麦从谷壳中分出来，我们要告诉他们他们有获取客观数据的系统。是的。他们想得到它。不仅仅是我看到了这个并写下来，而是实际上得到超自然的量化数据。绝对的。绝对的。安迪特别精通什么构成盲法研究以及这类事情。所以安迪是那个可以带头起草协议的人，这些协议将保持他们调查和结果的某种完整性。
And so then over the course of about nine years, they set about trying really hard to document science and to sort of like maintain their integrity in this field and sort of try to establish a brand that would mean something within this very sort of like squishy, topsy-turvy landscape of paranormal beliefs. And then, you know, over the course of time, they find that within their group, some of their members prioritize the hard search for evidence, which is sort of like the institutional view of ghost hunting. Like, let's prove it. Let's get those numbers. Let's find that evidence that suggests that we all live in a shared reality, even though that shared reality may
所以在大约九年的时间里，他们着手非常努力地记录科学，并有点像在这一领域保持他们的完整性，并试图建立一个品牌，在这个非常有点像糊状的、颠倒的超自然信仰景观中意味着什么。然后，你知道，随着时间的推移，他们发现他们的群体中，他们的一些成员优先考虑对证据的硬性搜索，这有点像捉鬼的机构观点。就像，让我们证明它。让我们得到那些数字。让我们找到那些表明我们都生活在一个共享现实中的证据，即使那个共享现实可能
be far different from what we have put into mainstream science. And that priority sort of butted heads against another priority of let's be inclusive. Let's accept everyone's word at face value and let's sort of like honor those individual experiences even if they don't seem to be, you know, true or compatible with other beliefs that we've also sanctioned and center, uh, to be, um, honored. And that is sort of like the, the, the fight that's going on in the paranormal community.
与我们投入主流科学的东西大不相同。而那种优先权有点像与另一种优先权相冲突，即让我们具有包容性。让我们以面值接受每个人的话，让我们有点像尊重那些个人的经历，即使它们看起来不是，你知道，真实的或与其他我们也批准和中心化的信仰兼容，要，嗯，被尊重。而这有点像，那个，那个，正在超自然社区中进行的斗争。
That's a, a diversity of thought. There's some people who feel like just to clarify for the audience, like there's some people who feel like you can just sort of subjectively contact the something and receive a subjective download of information and that's enough. And then there are other people who want to have, you know, objective proof that those things are real or some way of validating them in order to maintain that through science, the study of that.
那是一种思想的多样性。有些人觉得，只是为了向观众澄清，就像有些人觉得你可以只是有点主观地联系那个东西并接收主观的信息下载，这就足够了。然后还有其他人想要有，你知道，客观证明那些东西是真实的，或者某种验证它们的方式，以便通过科学，对那个的研究来维持这一点。
Exactly right. It's in personal experience. Someone gets up, the study of that experience and personal experience. Exactly right. So someone gets up at the UFO support group and says, I was abducted by an alien who looked like Mel Gibson in my bedroom and whatever sort of outlandish tale that you might come up with. And they would think, oh, geez, OK, so that guy is off base.
完全正确。这是个人经历。有人站起来，对那个经历和个人经历的研究。完全正确。所以有人在UFO支持小组站起来说，我被一个看起来像我卧室里的梅尔·吉布森的外星人绑架了，无论你可能想出什么样的离奇故事。他们会想，哦，天哪，好的，所以那个家伙偏离了轨道。
Yeah, what he is saying did not objectively happen. But so do you do you drum that guy out of the group and say, you know, this is not consistent with our search for evidence or do you say, oh, you know, this guy's had an experience sort of like that more therapeutic approach that you were talking about, Joel? Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, you have a couple people in the book that are the main characters. And then ultimately, they kind of have conflict and the ghost lab doesn't continue in the way that it is kind of set up in the beginning. Could you talk about that process and maybe its relationship to broader institution? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So it's, um, you're right.
是的，他所说的事情并没有客观发生。但是，你是否把那个家伙赶出小组并说，你知道，这与我们对证据的搜索不一致，或者你是否说，哦，你知道，这个家伙有某种经历，有点像你刚才谈到的那种更治疗的方法，乔尔？是的。是的。所以，你知道，你在书中有几个人是主要角色。然后最终，他们有点冲突，鬼魂实验室并没有以它开始时设置的方式继续下去。你能谈谈那个过程以及它与更广泛机构的关系吗？是的。是的。是的。所以它是，嗯，你是对的。
The sort of like competing priorities of, do we honor the individual experience versus do we prioritize the search for agreed upon evidence? Uh, those tensions sorted, sort of, um, started to manifest in some pretty sharp personality differences, where some people were very intent on being nice and other people were intent on being correct. And over the course of time, that led to all sorts of problems. And within the group, they had sort of like spiritual and supernatural explanations for a lot of the problems that happened. Andy in particular, one of the ways that this organization hoped to make money was by establishing a retail center, where they could sell their books and whatever supernatural ghost hunting gear and
那种竞争的优先权，我们是尊重个人经历还是优先考虑对商定证据的搜索？嗯，那些紧张局势有点，有点，嗯，开始在一些相当尖锐的个性差异中显现出来，有些人非常热衷于表现得好，而另一些人则热衷于表现得正确。随着时间的推移，这导致了各种各样的问题。在群体内部，他们对发生的很多问题有某种精神和超自然的解释。安迪特别，这个组织希望赚钱的方式之一是建立一个零售中心，在那里他们可以卖他们的书和任何超自然捉鬼装备和
that sort of thing. Andy was sort of like renovating a space. Andy had some carpentry skills and he's like building a counter and all that. He wound up renovating the space for like two years like building a counter and all that. He wound up renovating the space for like two years and not really making significant progress. But it was also like the only thing that he was giving his attention to. So the whole organization is sort of like suffering for his lack of attention.
那种事情。安迪有点像在翻新一个空间。安迪有一些木工技能，他就像在建一个柜台等等。他最终翻新了这个空间大约两年，就像在建一个柜台等等。他最终翻新了这个空间大约两年，并没有真正取得重大进展。但这有点像他唯一关注的事情。所以整个组织有点像因为他缺乏关注而受苦。
He is focused on the retail space. And at some point while he's building it, he realizes that when he's done, they will not be able to sell some of it because they don't have the money to sort of like buy inventory and stock the shelves and staff it. And so he's in this really sort of like odd place where he's just building and building and building and not getting anywhere. And they eventually sort of conclude that he is being victimized by a spiritual non-human entity, like an emotional parasite that is sort of creating this conflict within him and feeding off of it. And yeah, so eventually those sort of broader tensions
他专注于零售空间。在某个时候，当他在建造它时，他意识到当他完成时，他们将无法卖掉其中的一些，因为他们没有钱，你知道，购买库存并填满货架并配备人员。所以他处于一个非常有点像奇怪的地方，他只是在建造和建造和建造，并没有取得任何进展。他们最终有点得出结论，他正受到一个精神非人类实体的伤害，就像一个情感寄生虫，有点像在他内部制造这种冲突并以它为食。而且是的，所以最终那些有点更广泛的紧张局势
And yeah, so eventually those sort of broader tensions started to have the group fighting among themselves. This idea of objectivity versus individual experience, I think, is sort of like the disagreement that pour at the group. And it's also the disagreement that really has some implications for society because if the if the science guys within the paranormal community win you know if they are really dedicated to searching for evidence they can work within the confines and contexts of institutions that that honor You know, like they have to get funding for some outlandish ideas,
而且是的，所以最终那些有点更广泛的紧张局势开始让群体内部互相争斗。这种客观性与个人经历的想法，我认为有点像导致群体分裂的分歧。而且这也是确实对社会有一些影响的分歧，因为如果超自然社区内的科学家伙赢了，你知道，如果他们真的致力于寻找证据，他们可以在机构的限制和背景下工作，这些机构尊重，你知道，他们必须为一些离奇的想法获得资金，
but they can devise watertight experience and sort of like eventually in their worldview prove that ghosts are real or that, you know, certain psychic effects are real. Freud and Jung had that same fight, which I think in a dangerous method, he glamor, uh, glamorizes it, but it's the exact same.
但他们可以设计水密的实验，并有点像最终在他们的世界观中证明鬼魂是真实的，或者，你知道，某些通灵效果是真实的。弗洛伊德和荣格有同样的争吵，我认为在《危险方法》中，他美化了它，但它完全一样。
The dialogue is the same that they both recount happens where credibility. You can't go in this place. And Jung is like, I haven't ruled out that it's paranormal yet. I don't know if it's psychological or paranormal. I'm not gonna, I'm not, I want to, and Freud is like, no, I'm the scientist because I won't consider that. And Jung is like, well, I'm the scientist because I will't consider that. And Jung is like, well, I'm the scientist because I will. Um, and then I think, you know, you follow Jung, he does kind of rule out most of
对话是一样的，他们都叙述了发生的事情，可信度。你不能去这个地方。荣格说，我还没有排除它是超自然的。我不知道它是心理上的还是超自然的。我不会，我不会，我想要，而弗洛伊德说，不，我是科学家，因为我不会考虑那个。而荣格说，好吧，我是科学家，因为我会考虑那个。嗯，然后我认为，你知道，你跟随荣格，他确实有点排除了大部分
the broad strokes of the paranormal stuff. And he starts to see it more as a kind of the brainstem and a depth, you know, psychology connection to the older self. He doesn't really rule that out. And there's a lot of cranks now in the Jungian world and then grifters that borrow from that, but there's a lot of cranks now in the Jungian world and then grifters that borrow from that But it's an old fight Yeah, and Joe, you know so much about the sort of like history of psychology and one of my sort of like
超自然东西的广泛笔触。他开始更多地将其视为一种脑干和深度，你知道，心理学与旧自我的联系。他并没有真正排除这一点。现在荣格世界里有很多怪人，还有从那借用的骗子，但现在荣格世界里有很多怪人，还有从那借用的骗子，但这是一种古老的争吵。是的，乔尔，你知道很多关于心理学历史的东西，以及我的一种有点像
Takes from the book is that we might be seeing Sort of like the development of new professional a new professional class within the paranormal sort of like worldview that parallels the original development of psychology. Yeah, like it started off in a weird place, right? Or early psychologists, there was no clear definition of what that was. And one then technology makes us reconsider those assumptions again. I mean, in the 70s, you have which I'd like to talk at the end about how I think a lot of where we are now is the same place we were in the 70s, where people are just considering all this wild stuff. And technology has kind of changed our metaphor that helps us understand ourselves because that's always kind of we try to understand ourselves through the technology of the time. So it's like a watch is invented and people are like, maybe God is a watchmaker. Building is invented earlier and they're like, maybe God is an architect. And then now they're like, maybe God is an LLM,
书中的观点是，我们可能正在见证超自然世界观中某种新专业阶层的形成，这类似于心理学最初的发展。是的，就像它最初是在一个奇怪的地方开始的，对吧？或者说早期的心理学家，对于什么是心理学并没有明确的定义。然后技术让我们重新审视这些假设。我的意思是，在70年代，你所经历的——我想在最后谈谈——我认为我们现在所处的很多位置和70年代是一样的，人们只是在考虑所有这些疯狂的事情。技术在某种程度上改变了我们理解自己的隐喻，因为我们总是试图通过当时的各种技术来理解自己。就像发明了手表，人们会说，也许上帝是个钟表匠。更早之前发明了建筑，他们会说，也许上帝是个建筑师。而现在他们会说，也许上帝是一个大语言模型，
you know, or whatever. But like, in the seventies, there's all this new stuff. I mean, there's that Jungian current, but I mean, the CIA basically with like John C. Lilly and the Monroe Institute and people like that, they were like, we don't know that identical twins can't send pictures in each other's minds from the other room.
你知道，或者诸如此类的东西。但是，在七十年代，有很多新东西出现。我的意思是，有荣格的思潮，但我的意思是，中央情报局基本上和约翰·C·莉莉（John C. Lilly）、门罗研究所（Monroe Institute）以及类似的人一起，他们当时的想法是，我们不知道同卵双胞胎是否不能在隔壁房间把图像发送到对方的脑海中。
Maybe that would be helpful to fight Russia. Here's a million dollars. We don't know that you can't kill a goat by thinking really hard about it or burst clouds like Wilhelm Reich. John C. Lilly, here's a million dollars. Build a facility and feed LSD to dolphins. Maybe you can teach them to talk.
也许这对打击俄罗斯有帮助。这是一百万美元。我们不知道你是否不能通过努力思考来杀死一只山羊，或者像威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）那样让云层爆裂。约翰·C·莉莉，这是一百万美元。建一个设施，给海豚喂食LSD。也许你能教它们说话。
Maybe the reason dolphins don't talk is just no one fed them LSD and tried to yet. You know, they really did the experiment because they didn't know. And I mean, that was rolled out. It turns out that didn't work. But no one knew that, you know, Yeah, that that's absolutely true. Yeah. And science, yeah, they have like continue to sort of like take it up.
也许海豚不说话的原因只是还没有人给它们喂食LSD并尝试过。你知道，他们确实做了这个实验，因为他们不知道。我的意思是，那是在当时推出的。事实证明那没用。但没人知道，你知道，是的，那绝对是真的。是的。而科学，是的，他们不得不继续以某种方式将其捡起来。
And there's a there's a researcher in Arizona who built a lab that is still looking for some of these effects. And I think that's good. The public has a great interest in the paranormal. And for science to just sort of have retreated into a corner of skepticism, as justified as that may be, shows sort of like such a break and a disconnect from where the public space is. And scientists, I think they used to sort of like be able to coast on correctness, right? I used to be that a scientist, all they had to be was right.
亚利桑那州有一位研究人员建立了一个实验室，仍在寻找其中的一些效应。我认为这很好。公众对超自然现象有很大的兴趣。而科学如果只是退缩到怀疑论的角落里，无论这种怀疑多么合理，都显示出与公共空间的一种脱节和断裂。而且我认为，科学家们过去似乎能够依靠正确性来维持，对吧？过去，科学家只需要正确就行了。
And I don't think that's the world we live in anymore. You know, I think they need to sort of like, have a they have to worry about a trust with the public. And then you should have a perspective, you know, and not the right answer, maybe, because science is always looking for the next right answer. It should be sort of a mode of being that makes sure that people don't get hurt. Like, and we can talk about some of your conclusions at the end. I'd like to stay with the characters for a minute. But I'm struck by like how much the evidence based practice because I mean, I write about
我不认为我们现在还生活在那个世界里。你知道，我认为他们需要某种程度上，他们必须担心与公众的信任关系。而且你应该有一个视角，你知道，也许不是唯一的正确答案，因为科学总是在寻找下一个正确答案。它应该是一种确保人们不受到伤害的存在方式。比如，我们可以在最后谈谈你的一些结论。我想先和这些角色待一会儿。但我对循证实践的程度感到震惊，因为我的意思是，我一直在写关于
that all the time. But like you're saying the same thing in the book, you know, I'm assuming you're not reading my writing, and there's like this idea of evidence-based practice making something true or false, that I think there need to be more layers than that. Like if you're a medical provider and you say, hey, you've got stage four cancer, but we're not going to do chemo, we're not going to do surgery, I want you to do Reiki, I want you to do crystals. I want you to do, um, you know, prayer circles. I think that you shouldn't have a medical license. I mean, like, I don't think you should have one, but Reiki is evidence
那个话题。但就像你在书中所说的那样，你知道，我假设你没有读过我的文章，有一种关于循证实践使某事变得真实或虚假的观点，我认为这需要更多的层次。比如，如果你是一名医疗提供者，你说，嘿，你得了四期癌症，但我们不做化疗，我们不做手术，我希望你做灵气疗法，我希望你用晶体。我希望你做，嗯，你知道，祈祷圈。我认为你不应该拥有医疗执照。我的意思是，我不认为你应该拥有一个，但灵气疗法是有证据
based to make outcomes better. You know, the Catholic church had this huge discussion because they're like, you're doing Reiki in the hospitals and you're doing it because it's an evidence based practice, like, you know, most we've shown that this makes outcomes better. There's some research like that about prayer. It's not really as strong, but the prayer circles make outcomes more. And if that's true that it does, who cares why, right?
支持能改善结果的。你知道，天主教会对此进行了巨大的讨论，因为他们说，你们在医院里做灵气疗法，你们这样做是因为它是一种循证实践，就像，你知道，大多数我们已经证明这能改善结果。关于祈祷也有一些类似的研究。它并不是那么有力，但祈祷圈确实能改善结果。如果这是真的，那谁在乎原因呢，对吧？
So I think the actual mechanism of healing, the primary thing, like yeah, you have to do chemotherapy. You have to tell people the outcome if they don't get chemotherapy or surgery. But if we know that like a diet that is low in sugar makes cancer tumors grow less, and that's a supplemental thing, like that shouldn't come first, you know, you don't want to be the characters in your last book that are treating cancer with baking soda. But if that helps, why are we not telling
所以我认为治愈的实际机制，最主要的事情，比如是的，你必须进行化疗。你必须告诉人们如果不进行化疗或手术的后果。但如果我们知道低糖饮食能让癌肿瘤生长得更慢，而这是一种补充性的东西，那它不应该放在首位，你知道，你不想成为你上一本书中那些用小苏打治疗癌症的角色。但如果这有帮助，为什么我们不告诉
every cancer patient that, you know, if someone says I want Reiki, and we know that once you do chemo, Reiki helps you feel better, why is that not allowed? You know, even if we, and I think there's a fighting about we want science to work on our own terms, that liberals are very, it's, you know, that I fucking love science movement and stuff. You know, a lot of those people, when you show actual science to them, they get angry
每一个癌症患者呢，你知道，如果有人说我想要灵气疗法，而我们知道一旦你做了化疗，灵气疗法能让你感觉更好，为什么这不被允许呢？你知道，即使我们，而且我认为有一场关于我们希望科学按照我们自己的条件运作的争论，自由派非常，你知道，那个“我他妈爱科学”运动之类的。你知道，很多人，当你向他们展示真正的科学时，他们会生气
because they want it to be like what they understand it to be and not what the evidence says. I mean, that isn't the scientific method either. You know, I don't know if that makes sense. Maybe understanding things that, you know, are the primary cause and effect that we understand. And then the one where the cause and effect is a little bit more murky, but the outcome is there and it's researched and randomized control trial proved it. So who are you to say that this isn't allowed? You know? Yeah, no, that's absolutely true. Yeah, we do all sort of like, adopt a shorthand understanding because we're not experts, right? Most of us are sort of looking to signs other than the actual research to understand what the scientific consensus is, right?
因为他们希望它是他们所理解的样子，而不是证据所显示的样子。我的意思是，那也不是科学方法。你知道，我不知道这是否有意义。也许理解那些，你知道，我们所理解的主要因果关系。然后是那种因果关系有点模糊，但结果存在，并且经过研究和随机对照试验验证的情况。所以你凭什么说这是不允许的？你知道吗？是的，不，那绝对是真的。是的，我们都以某种方式采用了一种速记式的理解，因为我们不是专家，对吧？我们大多数人都在寻找除实际研究之外的迹象来理解科学共识是什么，对吧？
And those markers of scientific consensus are themselves flawed and fuzzy. But then if you try to go the other way and actually read the research and wrap your head around it, you're much more likely to chase your own, you know, reinforce your own incorrect beliefs that then you are to actually get to the heart of the matter. But because you're, it's so difficult to sort of like way opposing viewpoints within the field properly. Well, it's like you talk about Mesmer in the book, who is the origin of hypnosis, or as it was called in Mesmerism, who it's Ben Franklin that ends up getting debunked and thrown out.
而那些科学共识的标志本身就是有缺陷和模糊的。但如果你试图走另一条路，真正去阅读研究并试图理解它，你更有可能去追逐你自己的，你知道，强化你自己的错误信念，而不是真正触及问题的核心。但因为你，在领域内适当地权衡对立观点是非常困难的。嗯，就像你在书中谈到麦斯麦（Mesmer）一样，他是催眠术的起源，或者正如在麦斯麦术中所称的那样，最终是本杰明·富兰克林（Ben Franklin）将其揭穿并抛弃的。
And Mesmer thought that hypnosis worked because of something called animal magnetism that is wrong, right? But the outcome was working. Like he got the mechanism incorrect. But there's a ton of medical hypnosis now that is evidence-based And so I think if you don't allow it to be like it works, but we don't know why Yeah, it's a question of like research. You know, how are you gonna know? Yeah, it's a question of like practicality versus sort of like certainty, right and you're you're saying and I agree um, if there is a practical benefit to be had from doing something, then by all means, let's do it. And if you don't understand why that's working,
麦斯麦认为催眠术之所以有效是因为一种叫做动物磁性的东西，那是错的，对吧？但结果是有效的。就像他弄错了机制。但现在有大量的医学催眠是循证的，所以我认为如果你不允许它像“它有效，但我们不知道为什么”那样存在，是的，这是一个关于研究的问题。你知道，你打算怎么知道？是的，这是一个关于实用性与某种确定性的问题，对吧？而你，你正在说，我也同意，嗯，如果做某事有实际的好处，那么无论如何，让我们去做吧。如果你不明白为什么它有效，
continue to study. We don't understand why Ozenthic works fully, right? We just have to make people lose. The Nathaniel Banderas B voice at the very end, you know I'm talking about, Taneo Banderas, be voice at the very end, you know, after you know, I'm talking about the nation, excellent. Oh, yeah.
继续研究。我们并没有完全理解为什么Ozempic有效，对吧？我们只是不得不让人减肥。最后那个安东尼奥·班德拉斯（Antonio Banderas）的声音，你知道我在说什么，安东尼奥·班德拉斯，最后的声音，你知道，在你之后，你知道，我在谈论那个国家，太棒了。哦，是的。
Yeah. At the very end, like one of the things in the flavor text is like, we do not know exactly why these next works. That's that's one of the things in there. Yeah, yeah. And so like, yeah, like if we can
是的。在最后，就像风味文本中的一件事是，我们不知道这些东西为什么有效。这是其中的一件事。是的，是的。所以，就像，如果我们可以
sort of like, you know, accept that when it's something that's sort of like Centrally located within the dominant paradigm. Why can't we? offer the same sort of like tacit support to something that is Coming from a more left field Place Well, I think you're always working with metaphors anyway coming from a more left field place. Well, I think you're always working with metaphors anyway, whether or not you want to be,
某种程度上，你知道，接受当它是某种位于主流范式中心的东西时。为什么我们不能？对来自更偏门地方的东西提供同样的默许支持呢？嗯，我认为无论如何你总是在使用隐喻，来自更偏门的地方。嗯，我认为无论如何你总是在使用隐喻，不管你是否愿意，
and it doesn't really matter how literally you take them. I mean, when you look at the amount of people that are religious or something that are using that to make meaning out of life, or I mean, even science, look at how science functions when you go to eighth grade and they tell you, well, there, if there's two electrons on the shell on the outside and there's two protons in the middle,
而且你把它们看得有多字面并不重要。我的意思是，当你看看那些宗教人士或者其他什么人，他们利用这一点来赋予生活意义，或者我的意思是，甚至是科学，看看科学是如何运作的，当你上八年级时，他们告诉你，嗯，如果外壳上有两个电子，中间有两个质子，
then the atom's happy. Well, not only is the atom like not actually happy, that's wrong. Like that's the way you teach science to an eighth grader because you can't sell, hey, there's particles popping in and out of existence, we think, and there's subshells and there's like 50 shapes and like these are the more efficient and they wanna be be in this subshell but like they titrate down.
那么原子就快乐了。嗯，原子不仅实际上并不快乐，那是错的。就像那是你教八年级学生科学的方式，因为你不能推销说，嘿，有粒子在进进出出，我们认为，还有亚壳层，有50种形状，而且这些更有效，它们想待在这个亚壳层里，但它们会滴定下来。
Like, like the little circle, all the things that you learn about actual science aren't real either. They're metaphors and symbols to understand a greater reality that is too overwhelming to help you make sense and start to, you know, I don't know if that directly applies, but it's like, we're always kind of working with these, these things that help us understand a reality that is more complex than we can understand anyway. And I think comfort with that makes us rely on certainty. And in my mind, the opposite of truth is not lies. It's certainty, you know, the zealot that, that, that doesn't, that thinks that they have figured out the perfect way to be and they're not willing to modify that Yeah, that's really interesting And didn't you write at one point that um You know sort of like physicists are much less beholden to quantifiable results Yeah that for them. It's almost more like an art that then you Kukule the guy who invented the benzene ring Which I mean I guess later leads to World War two because our automotive companies give you know Hitler the ability to turn
就像，小圆圈，你学到的关于实际科学的所有东西也都不真实。它们是理解一个更宏大的现实的隐喻和符号，这个现实太令人难以承受，无法帮助你理解并开始，你知道，我不知道这是否直接适用，但就像，我们总是以某种方式使用这些东西，帮助我们理解一个无论如何都比我们能理解的更复杂的现实。我认为对这种复杂性的适应使我们依赖确定性。在我看来，真理的对立面不是谎言。是确定性，你知道，那个狂热者，那个认为自己已经找到了完美的生存方式，并且不愿意修改它的人。是的，那真的很有趣。而且你不是在某个时候写道，嗯，你知道，某种程度上物理学家对可量化结果的依赖要少得多。是的，对他们来说，这几乎更像是一门艺术，然后是凯库勒（Kekule），那个发明了苯环的人，我的意思是，我想后来导致了第二次世界大战，因为我们的汽车公司给了希特勒将木炭转化为柴油的能力，他本来做不到的。这是一个没有石油的国家，他本来做不到第二次世界大战，如果，你知道，感谢亨利·福特，但是的，那个发明苯环的人K·凯库勒，他在梦中看到了蛇，衔尾蛇变成了数字8。而那些人中有很多在撒谎。爱因斯坦，外面有数百万条引语。但那些物理学家中有很多，
charcoal into Diesel fuel which he couldn't have done. It's an oil-less country he couldn't he couldn't have done World War two if you know, thank you Henry Ford, but yeah, the the guy who invented the benzene ring K Kukule, he saw the serpent and a dream, and the Ouroboros turned into a figure eight. And a lot of those people were lying. Einstein, there's a million quotes out there. But a lot of those physicists,
特别是那些从事核工程的人，我的意思是，他们都说这只是来自一种直觉，我在脑海中看到了这个，我理解它是如何工作的。然后我不得不让数学对上。而他们中有些人根本不喜欢数学，你知道，奥本海默和爱因斯坦以这种方式闻名，这是你做的最后一件事，就是尝试找出客观证明。我们已经知道它是这样工作的，只是因为我认为有创造力的人有一种直觉的观察方式。模糊的地方在于我们的直觉感觉像我们的创伤，而创伤感觉像直觉，它们在伪装。
especially the ones around nuclear engineering, I mean, they all said this just came from an intuition of I saw this in my mind and I understood how it worked. And then I had to make the math line up. And some of them didn't like math at all, which, you know, Oppenheimer and Einstein were famous for like, this is the last thing that you do is try and figure out the objective proof. We already know it works this way, just because I think there's a certain way of seeing that people that are creative have that is intuition. Where it gets murky is our intuition feels like our trauma and trauma feels like intuition, they masquerade.
很多邪教领袖，很多宗教虐待人物都是非常有直觉的人，但他们某种程度上把创伤放在了自我的位置上，反之亦然。我不想让你扮演太多的治疗师。但当你观察书中的这些人时，你能看到他们把自己的情感需求误认为是客观真理的地方吗？或者他们试图这样做？是的，书中我特别讲述了一个场景，浮现在脑海中
A lot of cult leaders, a lot of religious abusive religious figures are incredibly intuitive people, but they're sort of putting a trauma in the place of the self or vice versa. And I don't want to ask you to play therapists too much. But when you look at the people who are, you know, in this book, can you see places where they're mistaking their own emotional needs for an objective truth? Or they're trying to? to? Yeah, there's one scene that I recount in particular in the book that comes to mind
有三个女人，她们都是，你知道，某种程度上的通灵者或某种程度上的灵媒，她们在一个闹鬼的、某种前工厂的环境中。她们正在逐个进行，试图想出她们可以相互确认的个人印象，从而，你知道，某种程度上拥有一个客观真理，但她们在将自己的印象与他人隔离开来方面做得并不好。所以她们某种程度上是在引导对方得出某些结论。但她们在那个工厂里经历的是某种虐待狂强奸犯的鬼魂，对吧？这个鬼魂某种程度上努力去猥亵她们三个人。
where there are three women who are all, you know, some level of psychic or some level of medium and they are in a haunted sort of like former factory setting. And they're going through individually trying to like come up with individual impressions that they can confirm with one another and thereby, you know, sort of like have an objective truth and they're not doing a very good job of sealing their impressions off from one another. So they sort of like are leading each other into certain conclusions. But what they experience in that factory is the ghost of sort of like an abusive rapist, right? And this ghost sort of like makes an effort to molest all three of them individually.
她们都有这种作为性侵犯对象的经历。然后她们一起工作来做出回应。所以她们真的某种程度上依靠彼此，某种程度上肯定了她们的，我称之为姐妹情谊，并一起工作来束缚那个鬼魂，你知道，击退他，剥夺他的力量，并将他送出这个存在层面。这对她们来说是赋权的。它被描述为一种治愈体验。这让我想起治疗师在咨询或类似场合中，
And they all have this sort of like experience of being the object of a sexual assault. And then they work together to sort of like respond. And so they really sort of like lean on one another, sort of like affirm their, I'll call it sisterhood, and work together to sort of bind up that ghost and, you know, rebuff him, rob him of his power and send him off of this plane of existence. And it's empowering for them. It's described as kind of a healing experience. And it reminds me of how often a therapist in a consultation or something,
你知道，我们提出你必须在人产生洞察力之前验证情感现实。很多人进来，他们描述的事情让他们觉得他们是受害者，而你知道他们并不是，他们可能，他们的行为是不对的，或者其他什么。但如果你没有同理心，说，是的，你在那一刻有这种感觉，这很难，你不想说你有权进行糟糕的行为
you know, we present that you have to validate the emotional reality before the person has insight. A ton of people come in and they're describing things where they feel they were the victim and you know that they weren't, that they probably, their behavior was not okay or whatever. But if you don't have empathy and say, yeah, you felt this way in that moment and this was hard and you don't wanna say you have a right to bad behavior
因为你是一个受害者，但你确实想说，就像是的，你的情绪是有效的，而且你确实受到了伤害。那是你当时的角度。那条线是灰色的。这很难。这是一个关于在变成纵容之前，你该验证到什么程度的大讨论。
because you're a victim ever, but you do wanna say, like yes, your emotion is valid and like you are hurt. And that was your perspective at that time. And that line is gray. It's hard. That's a big conversation of how much do you be validating before that becomes enabling.
我把界限划在处方上。我永远不想说我相信我不相信的东西。我永远不想说，你应该做这件事，因为它感觉很好，尽管它不健康。我永远不想做那件事，我相信我不相信的东西，我永远不想说你应该做这件事，因为它感觉很好，尽管它不健康。我永远不想做那件事。但你想要能够尽可能地容纳这个人的情感体验。而这正是你在观察的这些社区中自然演变的东西。是的，是的，绝对。而那个特定的经历真正让我震惊的是，
I draw that at the prescription. I don't ever want to say that I believe something that I don't believe. And I never want to say, you should do this thing because it feels good when it isn't healthy. I don't ever want to do that I believe something that I don't believe and I never want to say you should do this thing because it feels good when it isn't healthy. I don't ever want to do that. But you want to be able to hold the emotional experience of the person as much as you can. And that's kind of what evolves kind of naturally in some of these communities that you're observing. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. And what really struck me about that particular experience was that,
是的，绝对。而那个特定的经历真正让我震惊的是，它只是某种非常干净的东西，一点也不混乱。在这里，施虐者没有朋友，在法律体系中没有影响力，不会回过头来指责她们在性侵犯问题上撒谎。他只是某种彻头彻尾的邪恶实体。她们能够，你知道，某种程度上成为法官、陪审团和刽子手，对他施加完全的权力并把他送走。而这与
Yeah, absolutely. And what really struck me about that particular experience was that it was just sort of like a very clean, it wasn't messy at all. Here, the abuser had no friends, had no pull with the legal system, was not going to turn around and accuse them of lying about their assault. He was just like sort of like a flat out evil entity. And they were able to, you know, sort of like be judged, jury and executioner and exert complete power over him and send him off. And that is in such
她们在现实世界中可能被迫如何应对那种情况或那些感受形成了鲜明的对比。是的，而且你知道，我还要说，像你一样，我不知道这三个女人的个人历史，无法说她们是否会认为自己是性侵犯的受害者。但当然，有些人直到治愈后才意识到，你知道，这是过程的一部分。她们不会，你知道，我一起工作的很多人有非常极端的
contrast to, you know, how they might be forced to navigate That sort of a situation or those feelings in the real world Yeah, and you know, and I'll also say like you I I don't know enough about the personal histories of the three women to say Whether they would consider themselves to be Victims of sexual assault themselves But sure and some people don't until they've healed, you know, it's it's part of the process They're they're not gonna you know, a lot of people I work with have real extreme
你知道某种暴力的政治信仰，无论哪种方式，一旦治疗结束，她们会说，哦，你知道，我不再相信那个了，我不知道，因为我们没有谈论我很高兴她们不相信。但如果我，但你知道，就像是治愈导致了洞察力的产生。而且你知道，就像创伤患者，任何有创伤的人，很多时候我们重温同样的经历，试图控制它，这是一种试图治愈的无意识方式。
You know kind of violent political beliefs one way or the other and once therapy is done They're like, oh, you know, I don't believe that anymore and I don't know that because we didn't talk about what I'm glad that they don't But if I but you know, like it's the healing that makes the insight happen. And you know, like trauma patients, anyone with trauma, like a lot of times we revisit the same experience to try and have control over it and this kind of unconscious way of trying to heal.
如果有人经历过性侵犯或其他什么，我的意思是，作为一名治疗师，我宁愿她们去参加降神会或一个能帮助她们在情感上互相支持的团体，无论那意味着什么，也不愿她们进行过度性行为来试图证明，或者在与陌生人的危险情况下试图证明她们可以进去并重新掌握它。我的意思是，其中一个对我来说更可取。
And if somebody has experienced sexual assault or something, I mean, as a therapist, I would so much rather them go to a seance or a group that is gonna help them hold each other emotionally, whatever that means, then engage in hypersexuality to try and prove or dangerous situations with strangers to try and prove that they can go in and remaster that. I mean, one of those is preferable to me.
我的意思是，并不是说在某些精神团体中没有虐待因素。我的意思是，任何一个对我来说都更可取。我的意思是，并不是说在某些精神团体中没有虐待因素。我的意思是，任何团体都可能有这种情况，但是，你知道，风险看起来比在Grindr上找人要小得多，你知道吗？绝对。嗯，我认为，我的意思是，有时会出现的一件事是
I mean, not that there's not an abuse of element sometimes in some spiritual groups. I mean, any of those is preferable to me. I mean, not that there's not an abuse of element sometimes in some spiritual groups. I mean, any group can have that, but, you know, the risk looks a whole lot less than getting on Grindr or something, you know? Absolutely. Well, I think, I mean, one of the things that has come up with me sometimes
当某人对宗教有执念时，或者我必须知道这一点，而我不知道，我在这里想要确定性。我的意思是，我只会退后一步，谈谈知识的局限性。你知道，就像你知道宇宙是我们所说的正在膨胀的东西，但我们真正指的是我们在内部可以测量的空间量正在增加，而且时间、温度和，你知道，速度与空间之间存在这种关系。我们可以看到这个规则球。从内部看，看起来它更多了。
when somebody has a fixation on religion, or I have to know this and I don't know I want certainty here. I mean I'll just kind of back up and talk about the limits of knowledge. You know like you know the universe is this thing that we say is expanding but what we really mean is that the amount of space we can measure on the inside is getting more and that there's this relationship between time, temperature and, you know, speed and space. And we can see this ball of rules. And from the inside, it looks like there's more of it.
我们根本不知道外面有什么。我的意思是，我不知道。我是治疗师，不是牧师。而且，嗯，你知道，我们谈论，就像我经常和我的女儿交谈，你知道，我们阅读神话和世界宗教以及她现在感兴趣的不同事物，嗯，她七岁。所以我们去参加一些，你知道，圣公会教堂礼拜或其他不同的事情。她会问我，你知道，什么东西是真的，它们是怎么真的？
We have no idea what's on the outside. I mean, I don't know. I'm a therapist, not a priest. And, um, you know, we talk like I talk to my daughter a lot, you know, we read mythology and kind of world religions and different things she's interested in that right now and, um, she's a seven. So we go to some, you know, Episcopal church services or different things. And she'll ask me, you know, what things are true and how are they true?
所以这一切的本质有点意思。我想尊重她的发展，并为她留出空间来拥有代理权和好奇心。她对我说的其中一件事，我们就像，晚上阅读或讲故事。我们在吊床上，她就像问，嘿，但它是怎么到这里的？你知道，一直追溯到大爆炸的问题。
So the nature of all that is kind of interesting. And I want to be respectful of her development and kind of leave room for her to have agency and curiosity there. And one of the things she said to me, we were like, we like read or tell stories at night. We were in the hammock and she was like asking like, yeah, but how did it get here? You know, the question of all the way back to the kind of the big bang.
我说，嗯，你知道，在开始的时候，它只是这个微小的白光点，热量，一切都在一起。我们无法真正看到那个时刻之后。所以我们所有的科学只是把我们带回那个时刻，但我们真的不知道它为什么在那里。我们无法真正看到那个时刻之后。所以我们所有的科学只是把我们带回那个时刻，但我们真的不知道它为什么在那里。我们真的不知道。我们无法通过客观性看到那之后，你知道。
And I was like, well, you know, in the beginning it was just this tiny white dot of light and heat and everything was together. And we can't really see past that moment. So all of our science is just taking us back to that moment but we don't really know why it's there. We don't really see past that moment. So all of our science is just taking us back to that moment, but we don't really know why it's there. We don't really know. We can't see past that, you know, through objectivity.
她就像，你认为那就像上帝吗？我说，是的，你知道，就像我认为那确实是某种神秘感。她就像，我有点喜欢我们无法知道那一点，而不是其他。我觉得那是一种非常漂亮的处理方式，非常明智。是的，是的。
And she was like, do you think that's like God? And I was like, yeah, you know, like I think that that is kind of the mystery. And she was like, I kind of like that we can't know that more than that. I thought that was such a pretty way to kind of approach approach very wise Yeah, yeah
我的孩子们，我的孩子们真的很奇怪。在树林里和他们进行剑术对决。所以我们刚回来，但，嗯，是的，我的意思是，很多关于知识局限性的事情，以及我们也许应该有更多谦逊的地方，或者某种有趣的地方。但是，但你从来没有提出过这样的论点，比如，嗯，谁知道呢？每个人都有权拥有自己的观点。我的意思是，我喜欢你写作的一点是，你从来不，
My kids are my kids are really weird Day in the woods sword fighting with them. So we're we're just getting back but um, yeah, I mean A lot of those things about just kind of the limits of knowledge And where we should maybe just have more humility or kind of an interesting place. But that, but you never make a case that like, well, who knows? And everyone's entitled to their own perspective. I mean, I like about your writing is that you don't,
你从来不纵容，你也从来不通过回避来躲避一个难题。你知道，你说这些事情是坏的。我们知道它们是坏的。我不会重新考虑这些事情。但同时也像，也许我们不知道我们认为我们知道的那么多，或者我们还没有知道一切。我想知道，你知道，你是否可以谈谈你在书末的一些结论，关于“渡渡鸟群”的东西，以及科学也许需要改变或变得更大的想法。当我在读你写作的那一部分时，我在想西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）。
you don't ever enable and you don't ever just kind of duck a hard question through being avoidant. You know, you say these things are bad. We know they're bad. I'm not going to reconsider these things. But also like maybe we don't know as much as we think we do or we don't know everything yet And I wonder you know if you could talk about some of your conclusions at the end of the book the flock of dodo stuff And the idea that science maybe needs to change or get bigger. I was thinking of Theodore Porter when when
当你，当我读到你写作的那一部分时？是的，是的，你知道，我本质上就像，我某种程度上落脚于这个想法，即科学家已经失去了对他们信息的控制，对吧？他们可以产生我们有过的最客观的科学，多亏了某种程度上他们与资金来源之间的缓冲，
When you when I was reading that section of your writing? Yeah, yeah, you know I essentially like I sort of your writing? Yeah, yeah, I essentially like, I sort of landed on this idea that scientists have lost control of their messaging, right? They can produce the most objective science that we've ever had, thanks to sort of like the buffers between them and their funding sources,
对吧？在那里，公共纳税人资助了大量的研究，但他们某种程度上与公众成员的思考方式隔绝了，对吧？所以他们能够，这不像他们依赖于富有的赞助人，必须担心他们的分析，嗯，取悦那个赞助人，所以在那门科学中，你应该带回像约翰·迪伊（John Dee）在女王宫廷中为天使占卜，然后失去宠爱，是的，是的。所以，但那种脱节，某种程度上伴随着它自己的惩罚，就像许多优势一样。
right? Where, uh, the public taxpayer is funding a lot of research, but they're sort of isolated from how those, how the members of the public think, right? So they're able to, it's not like they're dependent on a wealthy patron and have to worry about their, their analysis, um, uh, pleasing that patronasing that patron so in that science You should bring back like John D scrying for angles in the Queen's Court and then like losing favor Yeah, yeah And so But that disconnect Sort of has its own penalty with it, as so many advantages
就像，他们可以做非常客观的科学，但他们与公众的脱节也意味着公众不一定理解、信任或重视那种科学，所以这很糟糕，对吧？我们想要一个公众，某种程度上会买账，进入科学给我们的进步，你知道，也许不像夸克跑出去时会发生什么，我们都只是某个黑洞中发生的事情的反射那样的软物理学，你知道，
do. Like, they can do very objective science, but their disconnect from the public also means that the public doesn't necessarily understand or trust or value that science right and so That's bad, right We want a public that will sort of like have some buy-in Into the advances that science gives us, you know Maybe not like the the squishy physics stuff of what happens when a quark goes out and we're all just a reflection of what's happening in a black hole somewhere like that, you know
公众尽管去吧，但当涉及到某种医学价值观，或者你知道，我们如何能建造最好的桥梁，或者我们如何能最好地衡量，你知道，坏水系统的影响，或者，你知道，我们如何能最好地控制病毒，或者，你知道，某种性传播疾病？就像这些是科学为自己设定的问题，公众应该真正倾听，对吧？因为它们对我们的世界有非常实际的影响、好处和坏处。所以科学需要某种程度上重新思考他们如何传递信息，对吧？
Have at it public but when it comes to sort of like that the values of medicine or You know, how can we build the best bridge or how can we sort of like best measure the, you know, the impacts of bad water system or, you know, how can we contain a virus or, you know, some sexually transmitted disease best? Like these are questions that science sets themselves to that public ought to be really listening to, right? Because they have very practical impacts and benefits and disadvantages for our world. And so science needs to sort of like rethink how they message, right?
他们不仅需要科学部门，他们还需要某种信息部门，这将有助于交流结果。而当科学家某种程度上正在进行他们自己的自我检查时，就会产生一部分，某种程度上，不仅仅是掩盖他们，他们某种程度上精英主义的观点，而是真正接受那些精英主义的观点，对吧？并真正从一个更谦逊和透明的地方说话。每个人都同意，你知道，公共资助的科学应该是透明的，但透明度的一部分是某种程度上承认那些怀疑并承认那种谦逊。而且对科学家公平地说，通常科学家会某种程度上发表一个带有四五个限定词的声明，
They don't just need the science arm, they need sort of like a messaging arm that will help to communicate the results. And part of that comes when scientists are sort of like undergoing their own gut check, and sort of like, not just papering over their, their sort of like elitist views, but truly coming to terms with those elitist views, right? And truly speaking from more of a place of humility and transparency. Everyone agrees that, you know, publicly funded science should be transparent, but part of transparency is sort of like acknowledging those doubts and acknowledging that humility. And to be fair to the scientists like oftentimes a scientist will sort of like make a statement that is couched in four or five qualifiers
比如，如果这是正确的，并且这值得进一步研究，那么这颗行星上可能存在生命，对吧？K到任何新闻需要五秒钟关于其他行星生命的音效，你知道，正确，正确。是的。是的。所以确实存在某种。而且如果新闻不这样做，那么党派团体或特殊利益团体就会控制那些信息。而且通常确实控制那些信息，并以有利于他们个人议程的方式。所以那座桥需要建立得更好。我确实在书中的一个章节中建议，如果科学家能够某种程度上在他们传播发现的一些方式中重新注入一种惊奇感和敬畏感。例如，关于一个人死后能量会发生什么。对此有很多精神上的答案，
Like if this is correct and and that bears further study then there might be life on this other planet, right? K to whatever that the news needs a five-second sound bite of life on other planet, you know, correct, correct. Yeah. Yeah. And so there is sort of like this. And if the news didn't do it, then partisan groups or special interest groups would control that messaging. And oftentimes do control that messaging and the ways that advantage their personal agendas. And so that bridge needs to be built out much, much better. I do sort of suggest in one section of the book that if scientists could sort of like re-enseal a sense of wonder in and all in some of the ways that they disseminate their findings. For example, about what happens to the energy of a human being after that human dies. There's a lot of spiritual answers for that,
但生物学并没有真正发布自己的信息，这可能非常美丽。它自己的某种信息，这可能非常美丽。对吧？所以……嗯，很多最大的科学家确实做到了，我的意思是，有那个，你读过爱因斯坦写给那个死亡的，我忘了名字，但他有一个同事去世了，你写了一封信给妻子。
but biology hasn't really put out its own message, which can be quite beautiful. its own sort of like message, which can be quite beautiful. Right? And so... Well, where a lot of the biggest scientists did, I mean, there's the, have you read that letter that Einstein wrote to the death of, I forget the name, but he had a colleague that died and you wrote a letter to the wife.
他说，像我一样了解量子物理学的人和你丈夫相信所有事物通过时间结合的必然性之类的。我不记得了。这非常有诗意，我的意思是，一些最聪明的科学家身上的谦逊感。我的意思是，在我看来，他们不是问题所在。就像我从来没有见过那些巨大的创新者。我在电话里和很多人谈过，你知道，不在播客上，我像网络一样联系很多人。
And he said, somebody who knows as much about quantum physics as me and your husband believe in the inevitability of all things to like conjoin through time or something. I don't remember it. It's very poetic and I mean, the sense of humility in some of the smartest scientists out there. I mean, in my mind, they're not the problem. Like I've never met the people that are the huge innovators. And I talked to a lot of people on the phone that you know aren't On the podcast and I like network a lot of people
而且就像我总是被我们时代一些最优秀头脑的创造力和强大直觉下的谦逊所打动。你知道，是的。是的，我认为那绝对是真的。是的，就像当他们瞄准那个水平时，他们可以非常强硬。是的，你知道，对于那个水平，他们可以非常强硬，你知道，过度成就者，但当他们达到那个水平时，几乎就像他们的，他们的整个存在可以放松，某种程度上利用那个崇高的栖息地来获得这样的智慧和洞察力，某种程度上，我想，对自己是谁感到安慰。我认为这真的，真的帮助他们某种程度上实现了这一点。嗯，我认为最糟糕的是那些做某种政治或科学的人，他们某种程度上抹黑了那些事情，就像，你知道，就像我喜欢，我们有同样的目标，
And like I'm always struck by the humility under the creativity and the powerful intuition of some of the best minds of our time You know, yeah. Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. Yeah, like When they're shooting for that level they can be really brass knuckles. Yeah, you know for that level, they can be really brass knuckles, you know, overachievers, but when they get that level, it's almost like their, their whole being can just like relax and sort of like use the use that lofty perch to gain such wisdom and insight and sort of like, I guess, comfort in who they themselves are. I think that that really, really helps them to sort of achieve that. Well, I think that the worst ones are the worst people that are doing kind of politics or science that kind of discredit the things that it's like, you know, like I like, we have the same goal,
但我认为他们正在做的事情实际上让情况变得更糟。是那些几乎像大厅管理员的人，他们就像，我必须为你树立一个好榜样，因为我比你强，而且你不知道所有的信息。所以，因为我的意思是，我和同事或某人进行的谈话中有一半，我只是觉得他们正在做的事情是非常无效的，
but I think that what they're doing actually makes it worse. Are the ones that are almost like hall monitors where they're like, I have to set a good example for you because I'm better than you and you don't know all the information. And so, cause I mean, like half of the conversations I've had with a colleague or somebody where I just feel like what they're doing is deeply ineffective,
无论是为了政治倡导还是为了某种科学倡导。当我像说，嘿，看，我的意思是，这就是你正在说的这些话。那是一个非常傲慢的简化。我99%的时间得到的是他们像，哦，好吧，你和我都知道这一点。但是，当你拥有那种态度和倡导时，我认为你会得到一个强硬的，通常是非常右翼的反应，这是完全合理的，因为它很烦人。就像，而且它，你知道，而且它就像那种轻率的无神论者，就像两千年代初的，你知道，我，你知道，任何时候有人在上面谈论，比如，
either for political advocacy or for kind of scientific advocacy. When I say like, hey, look, I mean, like this is this is you're saying these things. And that's a really kind of condescending simplification. What I get 99% of the time is them being like, Oh, well, you and I know that. But, and when you have that attitude and advocacy, I think you get a hardcore, usually very right-wing reaction to you that is totally justifiable because it's annoying. Like, and it's, you know, and it's like the light and atheist thing and like the early two thousands of like, you know, I, you know, anytime anybody's up there talking about like,
哦，我是一个只受逻辑影响的逻辑存在，你只是没有意识到你的情感体验，它在控制你并颠覆你的意图，你知道，很多时候。是的，就像社会正义运动最好的一点是它想要带来某种社会正义，但社会正义运动最糟糕的一点是它某种程度上迎合了这种人类倾向，即对别人感到高人一等。
oh, I'm a logical being that only is affected by logic You're just not aware of your emotional experience and it's and it's in control of you and subverting your intention You know a lot of the time Yeah it's like the best thing about the social justice movement is that it wants to bring about like social justice but the worst thing about the social justice movement is that it sort of plays into this human tendency to Uh feel holier than thou about somebody else.
你说过，你知道，那件我不会说的事情。让我们谈谈那个一个小时。对。是的。而那是如此适得其反，毫无帮助且孤立。仅仅是这个问题，比如，这在帮助谁，会触发这么多左翼团体，你会像，好吧，你已经（你知道，你正在做一个30分钟的土地确认，你知道，你知道，这是更多为了你还是更多为了事业？我认为很多人，你知道，
You said that, you know, that thing that I wouldn't say. And let's talk about that for an hour. Right. Yeah. And that is so counterproductive and unhelpful and isolating. Just the question, like, who is this helping will trigger so many leftist groups where you're like, okay You've got you know, you're doing a 30-minute law and acknowledgement, you know, you know Is this something that is more for you or more for the cause and I think a lot of people that you know are
审美上是左派，但也许内心更自由和反动，他们正在做的是他们在谈论他们想要帮助的人群。你在科学中也看到了这一点。我不是想改变话题，但就像他们在谈论他们想要帮助的人群，就像他们是这个受害者，无论什么，但实际上你在谈论你，
Aesthetically left but maybe more liberal and reactionary at heart what they're doing is they're talking about the population that they wanna help. And you see this in science too. I'm not trying to change the topic, but like they're talking about the population they wanna help, like they're this victim that whatever, but really you're talking about you
而且你还没有做你的工作来意识到你只是试图某种程度上获得验证。我不知道这是否有意义。你某种程度上误解了自己。而这就是当你进来，你就像，好吧，有效地，我们如何帮助这个人群？而且就像，作为一名社会工作者，就像，我们能做什么？而且就像，我们可以给他们这些选择和这些结果。那个说，不，不，不，这个群体所做的任何事情都不是他们的错。他们是在谈论他们自己。他们不想要后果。那就是那种受害者左派。那没有帮助，
and you haven't done your work to realize you're just trying to kind of get validation. I don't know if that makes sense. You're kind of mistaken for yourself. And that's when you come in and you're like, okay, effectively, how do we help this population? And like, can as a social worker, like, what can we do? And like, we can give them these choices and these outcomes. The person who says, no, no, no, nothing that this group of people does is their fault at all. They're talking about themselves. They don't want consequences for them. That's the kind of victimhood leftism. That's not helpful
就像那个投射的，你知道，我总是认同施虐者的右翼一样，因为很多右翼政治也是一种情感反应，在那里你有某个人说这群人是同性恋，或者他们是黑人，或者他们是弱势群体，而你走，不，不，不，那是自由市场者。那是上帝，或者无论什么，就像那个，那是上帝。他们没有足够的信仰，那只是你的情感现实在为施虐者寻找一个逻辑解释，在每种情况下都是对的，因为我像施虐者，对吧？那不是真的。你知道，我们是国家，我是个直率的人。是的，是的，是的。
Any more than the projected, you know I'm going to identify with the abuser all the time right wing thing because a lot of right wing politics are also an emotional response Where you have somebody that says this group of people's gay or they're black or they're vulnerable and you go no, no No, that's the free marketer. That's god or whatever like the lot that's god. They don't have enough faith that that's just Your emotional reality is looking for a logical explanation for the abuser is right in every situation because I'm like the abuser right? That's not real. You know, we're countries I'm a straight shooter Yeah, yeah Yeah
如果超过了预期，你知道我总是会认同施虐者，也就是右翼那一套，因为很多右翼政治也是一种情绪反应。当有人说这群人是同性恋、黑人或者是弱势群体时，你会说不，不，不，那是自由市场派，那是上帝，或者诸如此类。他们没有足够的信念去相信那只是你的情感现实在为施虐者寻找一个逻辑解释，认为他在任何情况下都是对的，因为我就像那个施虐者，对吧？那不是真的。你知道，我们是国家，我是一个直率的人，是的，是的，是的。
I mean and so so much of politics to me is just trauma and a lot of that informs the way that we Deal with science. I mean you see those same fights in academia, which is why academia is kind of frustrating, I think. That's really interesting. Yeah. And what one thing that I talked about in the book is sort of the difference between how practitioners treat people who have been possessed by gin, right? Whose work is that? What was the name? I'm blanking on the name. Um, I am, um, not remembering her name fully either. Um, but she, she was a PhD candidate at, I believe UCAL.
我的意思是，对我来说，政治中很大一部分只是创伤，而其中很多创伤影响了我们处理科学的方式。我的意思是，你在学术界也会看到同样的争斗，我想这就是为什么学术界让人感到沮丧的原因。这真的很有趣。是的。我在书中谈到的一件事是，从业者对待那些被精灵附身的人的方式有什么不同，对吧？那是谁的作品？名字是什么？我一时想不起来了。嗯，我也没完全记住她的名字。嗯，但她，她当时是博士候选人，我记得是在加州大学。
Um, and she sort of did this really interesting side by side comparison of people who have been possessed by gin and people who have been possessed by a Jinn and people who have been abducted by aliens. And how in the Muslim world, people who have been possessed by Jinn, which is a very pervasive widespread belief, have a therapeutic clinic-based outlet for that belief. Right, when they go to see their clinical therapist who's fully trained in all the medical stuff and they say, I'm having this problem,
嗯，她做了一个非常有趣的并排比较，比较了那些被精灵附身的人和那些被外星人绑架的人。在穆斯林世界，被精灵附身的人——这是一种非常普遍且广泛的信仰——有基于临床的治疗渠道来应对这种信仰。对吧，当他们去看受过全面医学训练的临床治疗师，并说“我有这个问题”时，
one of the tools in that clinical practitioner's toolbox is sort of like to create a therapy that speaks in the language of gin possession, where a holy man can be brought in and they write some special words from the Koran onto some paper that can be dissolved in water and drunk by the afflicted. And that is proven to be like a very practical and effective treatment. proven to be like a very practical and effective treatment. And it, it sort of like Trojan horses, some treatment practices that are recognized by Western science in terms of like, you know, peer support and frequent check-ins and, and, and that sort of
那位临床从业者的工具箱里的工具之一，就是创造一种用精灵附身语言交流的疗法，比如请来一位圣人，在纸上写下《古兰经》中的一些特殊词句，溶解在水中让患者喝下。事实证明，这是一种非常实用且有效的治疗方法。它有点像“特洛伊木马”，引入了一些被西方科学认可的治疗实践，比如同伴支持和频繁的随访，以及诸如此类的东西。
thing. But it also has its own sort of like spin and it just sort of comes from this other place. Whereas alien abductees, they don't get the sort of like mantle of cultural sensitivity, right? If an alien abductee walks into a clinical office in any country in the world and says, Hey, I've been abducted by aliens and I'm really afraid because I Worried it's gonna happen again There is sort of like there's no treatment for that other than this sort of like Cassette, you know
但它也有自己的特色，它来自另一个领域。然而，被外星人绑架的人却得不到这种文化敏感性的庇护，对吧？如果一个被外星人绑架的人走进世界上任何国家的临床办公室，说：“嘿，我被外星人绑架了，我真的很害怕，因为我担心它会再次发生。”除了这种……你知道的……之外，没有针对这种情况的治疗方法。
Well, I'm not gonna challenge your delusion. Well, that's what you're having Effectively psychology should say what symptoms is that causing? Well, I'm anxious. I'm scared. I'm not eating. I'm not sleeping Okay, let's deal with the emotion. Let's go through that. I mean what the person is saying happened Why fight about that at all? I don't see the point, you know Maybe they're just maybe it's real and the alien might come back and you still got to work with anxiety maybe it's not real and the person has you know made this metaphor that's more acceptable to their conscious mind for sexual abuse or something and it's easier to feel like I was taken to another planet and experimented on and then granddad touched me in the
好吧，我不会挑战你的妄想。好吧，这就是你正在经历的。实际上，心理学应该说：这导致了什么症状？嗯，我很焦虑。我很害怕。我吃不下饭，睡不着觉。好吧，让我们处理这些情绪。让我们经历这个过程。我的意思是，那个人说发生了什么，为什么要为此争论呢？我不明白意义何在，你知道吗？也许这是真的，外星人可能会回来，你仍然需要处理焦虑；也许这不是真的，那个人只是用了一个隐喻，这对于他们的意识来说更容易接受，用来掩盖性虐待或其他什么事情，感觉“我被带到另一个星球并被实验了”比“爷爷在木棚里摸了我”更容易接受。
woodshed and Your your therapy. I mean, how does it change? I mean the the insights gonna come back when the patient has capacity for it when the emotion is cooled down when the trauma response is not as much when you've recognized that emotion on the window of tolerance has gotten more. So I mean, why even sit there and say, Okay, what date? You know, I don't I don't understand why a lot of people need to kind of figure out what exactly happened. You're not a detective, you know, you're doing psychology. I think part of the root of it is that scientists and scientifically trained, evidence-driven practitioners don't want to put the wind beneath the wings of beliefs that they think are patently false. So if I start talking to you about the aliens, then I'm sort of like endorsing this idea of aliens that I do not think is true. I think that's sort of like the driving underlying motivation behind the reasons that scientists and, you know, those in healthcare and mental health fields in particular cause them to just sort
你的治疗，我的意思是，它是如何改变的？我的意思是，当病人有能力面对时，当情绪冷却下来时，当创伤反应减少时，当你认识到情绪并且“容忍之窗”变大时，洞察力自然会回来。所以，我的意思是，为什么要坐在那里问“哪一天”？你知道，我不明白为什么很多人需要弄清楚到底发生了什么。你不是侦探，你知道，你在做心理学。我认为其根源的一部分在于，科学家和受过科学训练、以证据为导向的从业者，不想为他们认为显然是错误的信仰提供支持。所以，如果我开始和你谈论外星人，那么我就等于在认可这种我认为不真实的外星人观念。我认为这就是科学家，特别是医疗和心理健康领域的从业者，导致他们只是……
of like dismiss or reject those things, to debunk them. And I think they think like, oh, yeah, we don't want to legitimize those beliefs and give them more power. But well, I don't know why you would need to legitimize it. I mean, I have to follow evidence-based practice. I have a board. I'm licensed. I have to justify any clinical intervention I do. And I don't sit there and say, yeah, I think the alien is real and this is what's happening any more than I would say, you know, sit there and focus on if the person's bringing in traumatic incident that's more plausible. I mean, I wouldn't sit there and be like, yeah, you know, what you
……只是驳回或拒绝这些事情，去揭穿它们。我想他们认为，哦，是的，我们不想让这些信仰合法化并赋予它们更多的力量。但是，我不知道你为什么需要让它合法化。我的意思是，我必须遵循循证实践。我有委员会。我有执照。我必须证明我所做的任何临床干预的合理性。我不会坐在那里说，是的，我认为外星人是真的，这就是正在发生的事情，就像我不会坐在那里专注于如果一个人带来的是更合理的创伤事件一样。我的意思是，我不会坐在那里说，是的，你知道，你……
the point of the treatment is to say, how's this affecting you? And how can you get better? And how can you change? So I mean, when I'm saying that you take it seriously, but not literally, I don't mean that you validate anything that is unhealthy. I just mean that there's not really a fight that I see you have to have from a therapy perspective. It's probably a level of nuance that's way above my pay grade because I'm not a therapist, but I would imagine that some practitioners would feel
治疗的重点是说：这对你有什么影响？你怎样才能好起来？你怎样才能改变？所以，我的意思是，当我说是“认真对待，但不是字面意思”时，我并不是说你要验证任何不健康的东西。我只是说，从治疗的角度来看，我看不出有什么必要去争论。这可能是一个远超我职权范围的细微差别，因为我不是治疗师，但我可以想象一些从业者会觉得……
that if they're not directly challenging it, then they are leaving the door open for that person to go home to their family and their concerned family member says, well, did the therapist tell you that you were wrong and that there's not a goblin under your bed? And have the patient say, no, no, he actually, he thinks that, he agrees that it's there,
如果他们不直接挑战它，那么他们就为那个人敞开了大门，让他们回家后，他们担心的家人会说：“好吧，治疗师有没有告诉你你是错的，你的床下没有妖精？”然后让病人说：“不，不，他实际上，他认为，他同意它就在那里，
but we're dealing with it. Yeah. Like that's, that's not the answer. Maybe that some concerned people would be looking for, you know, as, as off base as that might be. I've had patients that came in and felt like they were being gang stalked or that, um, and sometimes medication, you know, dopamine disorders need medication. I make everybody mad with my perspective on the podcast because people, you should say that crystals heal you without and I would throw your antipsychotic in the toilet. And I'm like, no, I don't think that. And then there's other people that are like,
但我们正在处理它。”是的。就像那不是一些关心的人可能在寻找的答案，你知道，尽管这可能有些离谱。我曾有病人进来，觉得他们被团伙跟踪，或者……有时药物，你知道，多巴胺紊乱需要药物。我在播客上发表观点时让每个人都生气，因为人们会说“水晶能治愈你，把你的抗精神病药扔进马桶里”。我说，不，我不这么认为。然后还有其他人说：
well, you're a crank and a pseudoscientist because you're open to something that I'm not. So I kind of get it from both sides, but none of those patients, I didn't endorse the thing that they were doing that was not gonna have a good result for them. I told them what the result of that is. If you tell people about this thing,
“好吧，你是个怪人，是个伪科学家，因为你对某些我不接受的事情持开放态度。”所以我从两方面都受到了批评，但对于那些病人，我并没有支持他们那些不会有好结果的行为。我告诉了他们结果会是什么。如果你告诉人们这件事，
they're probably gonna have this reaction because this isn't a common experience that a lot of people don't think about this. So if you keep doing it, you're probably gonna get that reaction. But this is what I would do with those emotions. And we did brain spotting, we did somatic experiencing. Some of them did QAG brain mapping and neuromodulation.
他们可能会有这种反应，因为这不是很多人会想到的常见经历。所以如果你继续这样做，你可能会得到那种反应。但这就是我会如何处理这些情绪的方法。我们做了脑点定位（Brainspotting），我们做了躯体体验（Somatic Experiencing）。他们中的一些人做了QAG脑图和神经调节。
And most of those people at the end of it said, I realized that this was actually sexual abuse and I didn't want to make that true because I thought I loved this person or I wasn't allowed to have these thoughts about him. But I never got there with anyone debating them and telling them, I will not endorse your belief because your belief is not. I just didn't do that. I don't think that's effective. I think that's a way that you make those people feel more alone and get them to leave. But I don't enable people. I mean, I'm the joke with my friends
最后，他们中的大多数人说：“我意识到这实际上是性虐待，我不想让它成为事实，因为我以为我爱这个人，或者我不被允许对他有这些想法。”但我从来没有通过辩论或告诉他们“我不会支持你的信仰，因为你的信仰不是……”来达到目的。我只是没那样做。我不认为那是有效的。我认为那是让这些人感到更孤独并让他们离开的一种方式。但我不会纵容人们。我的意思是，我和朋友开玩笑说，
is I'm like the anti-social worker. Like I'm not, I'll tell you what I think and I'm not gonna lie to patients. I'm not gonna lie to anybody really. And those are really powerful results. So yeah, I think you're maybe unusual in your ability to sort of like hold respect for without explicitly endorsing.
我是反社会工作者。我不……我会告诉你我的想法，我不会对病人撒谎。我真的不会对任何人撒谎。那些是非常强大的结果。所以是的，我想你在保持尊重而不明确背书的能力方面可能是不寻常的。
You know, I think there are a lot of people who cannot navigate that quite as deftly as you can. Well, I think that's sad. I think that's something that that should the industry should aspire to to make more common, you know, and not to be like me. Yeah, I don't have the answer for you. And I don't do all kinds of therapy, but to find ways to open the door to real people. You know, and if they are, if they are motivated by sort of like a desire to not endorse and legitimize the what they think of as sort of lackadue beliefs,
你知道，我认为有很多人无法像你那样巧妙地处理这个问题。好吧，我认为这很可悲。我认为这是行业应该努力使其变得更普遍的事情，你知道，而不是像我一样。是的，我没有答案给你。我不是做各种疗法，但要找到打开大门接触真实人的方法。你知道，如果他们是出于一种不想背书和合法化他们认为是“缺乏证据的信仰”的愿望，
my concern is that they are themselves becoming delegitimized by their refusal to sort of accommodate those sorts of beliefs. When you have large members of the public who are turning to ghost hunters and mediums and, and, um, uh, psychics and alien peer support groups to explain, uh, the world to them. Uh, people who are, you know, nothing against those, those, um, people who identify in those fields, but they are not, there's no training.
我担心的是，他们因为拒绝容纳这些信仰而让自己变得不合法。当你看到大量公众转向捉鬼人、灵媒、通灵者和外星人同伴支持小组来向他们解释世界时……那些人，你知道，并不是对那些在这些领域认同的人有什么意见，但他们没有受过培训。
I can hang out a ghost, uh, a ghost hunter shingle on my front door tomorrow. Right. And start accepting clients. And when they tell me that they're hearing voices or feeling uneasy I can tell them whatever the heck I want to Right. And so that's sort of like the danger There was a place I have a friend in Florence, Alabama And he had a neighbor who seriously needed help and she didn't have a lot of money and whatever and there was a very predatory Organization like every time she was trying to lot of money and whatever and there was a very predatory organization like every time She was trying to save this money and this van would pull up It looked like the scooby-doo mystery machine
我明天就可以在我的前门挂上一个“捉鬼人”的招牌。对吧。然后开始接受客户。当他们告诉我他们听到声音或感到不安时，我可以告诉他们任何我想说的话。对吧。所以这就是危险所在。有一个地方，我在阿拉巴马州佛罗伦萨有个朋友，他有个邻居确实需要帮助，她没有多少钱，不管怎样，有一个非常掠夺性的组织，每次她试图存钱，这辆面包车就会开过来，看起来像史酷比的神秘机器，
I don't remember the name of the company but it had some You know ghost stoppers or whatever and these people would go in with gas and stuff and she was trying to feed her kids And they had all these doodads and it's just clearly not what she needed. You know, it wasn't that the house The house was not the problem, you know, the environment was not the problem. It was something on the inside that needed to be witness That's how I mean that stuff is abusive. I mean, I don't think that I'm not endorsing exploiting anybody Yeah, yeah And so I think like if the
我不记得那家公司的名字了，但它有一些，你知道，“捉鬼敢死队”之类的东西，这些人会带着气体之类的东西进去，而她当时正试图养活她的孩子。他们有所有这些小玩意，这显然不是她所需要的。你知道，并不是房子的问题，你知道，环境不是问题。是内心深处需要被见证的东西。我的意思是，那些东西是虐待性的。我的意思是，我不认为……我不是在支持剥削任何人。是的，是的。所以我想如果……
And yet, you know people are you know that that? if the, um, and yet, you know, people are, you know, that, that, uh, customers, you know, that, that victim was more comfortable calling those ghost hunters in Scooby Doo Van than she was calling a legit practitioner. Um, and if the industry was more open, if there was more of a language who accept that, I don't know that the business model of the, you know, $2,000 visit ghost hunter would be there You know, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you can sort of like attack that on two fronts, right one you can require evidence based folks to be more open and inclusive and and have a welcoming environment for people who are in those worlds and two you can
然而，你知道人们是……你知道那个……如果，嗯，然而，你知道人们是，你知道，那个，那个……客户，你知道，那个受害者比起打电话给合法的从业者，更愿意打电话给那些开着史酷比面包车的捉鬼人。嗯，如果这个行业更开放，如果有更多的语言来接受这一点，我不知道那个两千美元一次的捉鬼人的商业模式是否还会存在。你知道，是的。是的。是的，你可以从两个方面来攻击它，对吧？第一，你可以要求循证从业者更加开放和包容，并为那些处于这些世界中的人提供一个受欢迎的环境；第二，你可以
sort of like create a a class of let's say ghost hunters who are licensed and who are trained. Yeah, maybe not. We're not in it for $2,000 an hour from people on, you know, welfare, basically. Yeah, right, right, right. Because they want to look for ghosts and yeah, better reasons. And people who are trained to sort of like mitigate the harmful effects that they might otherwise be prone to. You know, so like if the person describes hearing voices in their head, yeah, a licensed ghost hunter might say, all right, you know, I'm gonna look for demons, but let's also
创造一类，比如说，有执照且受过培训的捉鬼人。是的，也许不是。我们不是为了从领救济金的人那里赚每小时两千美元。是的，对，对，对。因为他们想寻找鬼魂，是的，更好的理由。而且是受过培训的人，可以减轻他们可能容易产生的有害影响。你知道，所以如果那个人描述在脑子里听到声音，是的，一个有执照的捉鬼人可能会说，好吧，你知道，我会寻找恶魔，但我们也
connect you with this therapist, you know, but let's also connect you with this therapist. But let's also sort of like the complimentary medicine approach. I think I said this in the quack book, in some states there are like state boards of homeopathy. I do not believe in homeopathy at all. It's got some very odd ideas at its heart that don't pass a smell test. But a lot of people believe in homeopathy and what these state boards do, like for example, in the state of Nevada
把你和这位治疗师联系起来，你知道，但我们也把你和这位治疗师联系起来。但我们也应该采取一种补充医学的方法。我想我在《庸医》那本书里说过，在一些州有顺势疗法州委员会。我根本不相信顺势疗法。它的核心有一些非常奇怪的想法，经不起推敲。但很多人相信顺势疗法，而这些州委员会所做的，例如在内华达州，
is they ensure that a homeopathic practitioner who's treating a cancer patient isn't telling that cancer patient to stay away from the doctor And they're ensuring that their practitioners are not having sexual relationships with it with their their clients or patients Yeah, so just sort of like maintaining a basis of ethics There's a
是确保治疗癌症患者的顺势疗法从业者不会告诉那个癌症患者远离医生。他们确保他们的从业者不会与他们的客户或病人发生性关系。是的，所以只是维持一个道德基础。有一个
astrology body in Birmingham or Alabama I know that because they have to refer to us They're they're more comfortable with our therapy Oh because they want to make sure that astrologers aren't saying I'm gonna treat your borderline personality disorder with planet They have some that's medical issue. So, you know, we'll get a call from from some of them That's absolutely fantastic. And like so what that does is that creates like in Birmingham, there's a, a class of fortune tellers who have found a home in the system and therefore have a stake in keeping this whole institutional thing rolling.
在伯明翰或阿拉巴马州有一个占星术机构，我知道这一点，因为他们必须转介给我们。他们对我们的疗法更放心。哦，因为他们想确保占星家不会说“我要用行星来治疗你的边缘型人格障碍”。他们有一些那是医疗问题。所以，你知道，我们会接到他们中一些人的电话。这绝对太棒了。所以这所做的是，在伯明翰创造了一类算命师，他们在系统中找到了归宿，因此在保持整个制度运作方面有既得利益。
Right. Well, I mean, doctors, if you go back to those medical boards of like, when people were fighting about herbal medicine, when it was all, you know, kind of whatever, I forget the name of the guy that wrote etedorfa, which is this really wild novel and he has this huge library of like herbal medicine when it was all, you know, kind of whatever. I forget the name of the guy that wrote Etidorfa, which is this really wild novel. And he has this huge library of like herbal medicine and his organization is one that lost, even though it has some better organizations that came now.
对。好吧，我的意思是，医生，如果你回到那些医疗委员会，当人们在争论草药医学时，当它全是，你知道，不管怎样，我忘了写《Etidorhpa》那个人的名字了，这是一部非常狂野的小说，他有一个巨大的草药医学图书馆，当它全是，你知道，不管怎样。我忘了写《Etidorhpa》那个人的名字了，这是一部非常狂野的小说。他有一个巨大的草药医学图书馆，而他的组织是失败的一方，尽管现在有一些更好的组织出现了。
But like, I mean, we licensed doctors of osteopathy, who believes in osteopathy? I mean, they're practicing medicine and they have to just because of this weird licensure requirement, if you get a DO instead of an MD, you have to memorize certain movements that bones do that don't do anything that don't heal you. I mean, like the school still has to do it. Cause it's part of their credentialing, but like no one thinks osteopathy.
但是，我的意思是，我们给骨科医生发执照，谁相信骨科？我的意思是，他们正在行医，他们必须这样做，只是因为这个奇怪的执照要求，如果你获得DO（骨科医生）而不是MD（医学博士），你必须记住骨头做的某些动作，这些动作没有任何作用，不能治愈你。我的意思是，学校仍然必须这样做。因为这是他们认证的一部分，但没有人认为骨科……
And you know, sorry to the one listener out there who will email me, but like generally even the D O's that I've talked to, you know, don't think that that works, but that's baked into this institution. You know, a lot of this stuff, you know, have you ever looked at that? It's, it's pretty weird. No, no. Yeah. I mean, I know a lot of DOs, they're great doctors, but a lot of people have, I mean, cause they practice medicine, they can do the same thing any EMD can do. Um, but there's just, there's just this added,
而且你知道，对那位会给我发邮件的听众表示抱歉，但总的来说，即使是我交谈过的DO，你知道，也不认为那有效，但这已经融入了这个机构。你知道，很多东西，你知道，你有没有看过那个？它，它很奇怪。不，不。是的，我的意思是，我认识很多DO，他们是伟大的医生，但很多人有，我的意思是，因为他们行医，他们可以做任何MD能做的事情。嗯，但只是，只是有这个额外的，
I mean, there were points in American history where there were like nine competing medical boards that all thought the other one was cranks. And for some reason, DLND are the ones that won. That's really, really funny. Are you familiar with Joseph Campbell? I know you play D&D. So probably some overlap. That sounds familiar, but I can't. He's like the hero, Joseph Campbell was like the mythographer from the seventies that like inspired Star Wars and a bunch of that stuff with the hero's
我的意思是，美国历史上曾有几个时期，有九个相互竞争的医疗委员会，都认为对方是怪人。出于某种原因，DO和MD是获胜的那些。这真的，真的很有趣。你熟悉约瑟夫·坎贝尔吗？我知道你玩D&D。所以可能有一些重叠。这听起来很熟悉，但我不能。他是那种英雄，约瑟夫·坎贝尔是七十年代的神话学家，启发了《星球大战》和一大堆关于英雄的东西。
journey, that idea. But him and like John Dominic Croissant, well, Joseph Campbell has this quote about myths are private dreams or yeah, myths are public dreams. Dreams are private myths. And John Dominic Croissant has like another line where he's talking about, I think he is Catholic, but he deals with kind of the psychology of religion
旅程，那个想法。但是他和像约翰·多米尼克·克罗桑（John Dominic Croissant）这样的人，嗯，约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）有句名言，说神话是私人的梦，或者说，神话是公共的梦。梦是私人的神话。而约翰·多米尼克·克罗桑有另一句台词，他在谈论，我想他是天主教徒，但他处理的是宗教心理学方面的问题
and how it represents these parts of self. And he has a thing where he was like, at the end of a talk, he'll stop and be like, I just wanna be clear that I'm not saying that ancient people talked in metaphors and we're now smart enough to decode them. I'm saying that we are now stupid enough to take metaphors literally.
以及它如何代表自我的这些部分。他有一件事，就是在演讲结束时，他会停下来，说，我只想明确一点，我并不是说古人是用隐喻说话的，而我们现在足够聪明去解读它们。我是说，我们现在愚蠢到把隐喻当真了。
And I mean, you look at like ancient Greece, Socrates gets executed saying that a ghost is talking to him that is probably a metaphor for a point that he's making. If you read Socrates, these things are kind of older. There's a lot of people that kind of go to the mat for subjective spaces being important with objective reality also. And I mean, that's such an old conversation. I don't know. I don't know if that is something that I'll hand that over to you. I don't know if any of that speaks to you or if that's just kind of out there needs to get cut out. Yeah, no, I mean, I think certainly like,
我的意思是，你看看古希腊，苏格拉底被处决时说有一个鬼魂在跟他说话，那可能是一个隐喻，用来表达他所持的观点。如果你读过苏格拉底的作品，这些事情就比较古老了。有很多人支持主观空间与客观现实同样重要。我的意思是，这是一个非常古老的对话。我不知道。我不知道这是否是我要交给你处理的事情。我不知道这些话是否对你有触动，或者这只是需要被剪掉的内容。是的，不，我的意思是，我认为当然，就像，
I think what it speaks to me is that it just sort of like reinforces this idea that like, well, I, you know, again, am an objective numbers science guy, you know, I'm far more a member of the skeptic community that than in any sort of believer community can recognize, you know, even I can recognize that people sort of like aren't built to just believe in objective science, right? People are built to believe in those myths and to believe in those dreams and to have those narratives that are hugely important to them, right? Much more important that, you know,
我认为它触动我的是，它只是强化了这样一个想法，即，嗯，我，你知道，再次重申，是一个客观数字科学的人，你知道，我更多是怀疑论者社区的一员，而不是任何信徒社区的一员，即使是我也能认识到，人们并不是为了仅仅相信客观科学而建立的，对吧？人们是为了相信那些神话，相信那些梦，并拥有那些对他们来说极其重要的叙事而建立的，对吧？比，你知道，更重要，
how many examples are there of, you know, the public doing something that is self-defeating because it serves sort of like a narrative, right? Yeah. And, you know And institutions have to learn how to sort of like tickle that part of the brain, and they have to learn how to accommodate those sorts of worldviews, or the institutions themselves will become obsolete. You know, history is littered with institutions that have become obsolescent and linked out of existence. And our current institutions, you know,
有多少例子是，你知道，公众做了一些自我挫败的事情，因为它服务于某种叙事，对吧？是的。而且，你知道，机构必须学会如何去触动大脑的那一部分，他们必须学会如何适应那些世界观，否则机构本身就会变得过时。你知道，历史上充斥着变得过时并最终消失的机构。而我们目前的机构，你知道，
we're sort of like in the bubble, right? We can't imagine a place without, you know, big hospitals and government and a massive church and all of this stuff. But right outside that bubble, there are times in human history and perhaps times in human future that are not sort of dominated by those centralized institutional power structures. And I think that that's a really frightening idea on some level, but it's also sort of like an opportunity on some level. And But it's also sort of like an opportunity on some level. And if institutions want to change that,
我们就像是在泡沫中，对吧？我们无法想象一个没有，你知道，大医院、政府、庞大的教会和所有这些东西的地方。但在那个泡沫之外，人类历史上确实存在，也许人类未来也会存在，不被那些集中的制度权力结构所主导的时期。我认为这在某种程度上是一个非常可怕的想法，但它在某种程度上也是一个机会。而且，在某种程度上也是一个机会。如果机构想要改变这一点，
they have to serve the people better. They have to share those dreams with the populations that they serve and find that closer space with the public. You know, they just need to, to, to hold more respect. And I would say that comes from giving the public more information, not being afraid of, well, the bigger the research study, the bigger the audience is the press. And so I'm going to try and withhold information or put up walls or condescend. I think that when you do that, you're really fueling right-wing extremism in a scary way.
他们必须更好地服务于人民。他们必须与他们所服务的民众分享那些梦想，并找到与公众更亲近的空间。你知道，他们只需要，去，去，保持更多的尊重。我会说这来自于给公众提供更多的信息，而不是害怕，嗯，研究规模越大，受众就越大，媒体也是如此。所以我打算尝试隐瞒信息，或者竖起高墙，或者表现出屈尊俯就。我认为当你这样做时，你实际上是在以一种可怕的方式助长右翼极端主义。
We saw some of that during COVID where people are saying, well, the public's not ready to know this information. They'll get too confused. And it fueled conspiracy theories. If they had just said, yeah, there are some, the problems with this or, you know, right now there's a shortage of masks, so please leave them for healthcare workers, you know, then I think they switched over to now everyone has to wear a mask, it would have felt, people would have felt more empowered, felt more informed and a part of the process.
我们在新冠疫情期间看到了一些这种情况，当时人们说，嗯，公众还没准备好知道这些信息。他们会感到太困惑。这助长了阴谋论。如果他们当时只是说，是的，有一些，这方面的问题，或者，你知道，现在口罩短缺，所以请把它们留给医护人员，你知道，然后我想他们转而说现在每个人都必须戴口罩，这会让人感觉，人们会感到更有力量，感觉更知情，并成为过程的一部分。
And I just watched that be so mishandled. Um, and, and things, um, I don't know. I mean, that be so mishandled and and things. I don't know. I mean, that is that kind of what you're saying or is that? Yeah, I mean, I think absolutely. Like, I find the lapses of transparency to be sort of less prevalent, I suppose. You know, they that we see them when there's a lot of heat and pressure on an issue So maybe an app point, you know to that point like they're the most they're choosing the most damaging times to be less than transparent
我只是看着这一切被如此糟糕地处理。嗯，而且，事情，嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，那是你所说的吗，还是？是的，我的意思是，我认为绝对是。就像，我发现透明度的缺失似乎不那么普遍，我想。你知道，他们，我们看到它们是在一个问题上有很大热度和压力的时候。所以也许是一个切入点，你知道，就这一点而言，就像他们选择了最糟糕的时机来表现得不够透明
Right. Yeah, I think other people like they're stupid. They will act like they're stupid, you know Yeah, if you treat people with respect they will they will Be more likely to rise to the occasion people with respect, they will be more likely to rise to the occasion. Yeah, yeah, I absolutely believe that. And, you know, and yeah, there is that sense that like, you can't you can't give the American public a hard truth. And everybody in government sort of like bending over backwards to do that. Yeah, yeah.
对。是的，我认为其他人就像他们很蠢。他们会表现得像他们很蠢，你知道。是的，如果你尊重人们，他们会，他们会更有可能挺身而出。尊重人们，他们会更有可能挺身而出。是的，是的，我绝对相信这一点。而且，你知道，是的，确实有那种感觉，就像，你不能，你不能给美国公众一个残酷的真相。政府里的每个人都在某种程度上竭尽全力这样做。是的，是的。
Yeah, you mentioned how like on the left they were withholding certain pieces of information or you know the the government was from this sort of like protectionist uh place but you know Trump was sort of doing the opposite where he was saying like oh yeah there's no COVID everything's fine. Yeah and when I don't think that's awesome that's just yeah that's just wrong I don't mean that isn't what I mean. Like you give them more information. Yeah. But it was that same sort of like protectionist, uh, idea of like, well, I don't want people to worry. They're both avoidant. They're both avoidant about a problem and avoidance.
是的，你提到了左派是如何隐瞒某些信息，或者你知道，政府是从这种保护主义的角度出发的，但你知道，特朗普却在做相反的事情，他说，哦，是的，没有新冠，一切都很好。是的，我不认为这很棒，那只是，是的，那只是错的，我不是那个意思。那不是我的意思。就像你给他们更多信息一样。是的。但这是一种同样的保护主义，嗯，想法，就像，嗯，我不想让人们担心。他们都在回避。他们都在回避一个问题，而且回避。
Yeah. To very bad stuff, I think. Yeah. Yeah. And so, yeah, I, I do think do think you know transparency is an issue, but I think it's Probably not the greatest issue from my perspective. I think yeah from my perspective We need more deliverable outcomes from government. Mm-hmm. We need folks to feel like they are in a stable Country yeah and a stable world You know what one of the you probably knew about this before I wrote about it, but there was an anthropologist who went to the South Pacific Islands around 1900 and documented the different fishing
是的。我认为这会导致非常糟糕的事情。是的。是的。所以，是的，我，我确实认为，你知道，透明度是一个问题，但我认为这可能不是我看来最大的问题。我认为，是的，从我的角度来看，我们需要政府提供更多的可交付成果。嗯哼。我们需要人们觉得他们生活在一个稳定的国家，是的，和一个稳定的世界。你知道，其中一个，你可能在我写它之前就知道这一点，但有一位人类学家在1900年左右去了南太平洋岛屿，记录了不同的捕鱼
techniques of some indigenous folks who lived in sort of like an island system. And when they wanted to catch fish from the coral reefs, they would sort of like, you know, mash up a poisonous root and stick it on a stick and go out and throw a net over a coral reef. Stick in the stick, the poison would come out of the root, the fish would flound her into the net and they would go home with dinner. And that was a very stable way to get food and it had no sort of like superstitious behaviors attached to it. Now they did the thing because they knew the thing worked and they knew that that would get them the calories and food they needed to see the next day. When those same folks went shark fishing,
一些生活在某种岛屿系统中的土著居民的技术。当他们想从珊瑚礁中捕鱼时，他们会，你知道，把一种有毒的根捣碎，粘在棍子上，然后出去，把网扔到珊瑚礁上。把棍子插进去，毒药会从根部流出来，鱼会挣扎着进入网中，然后他们就会带着晚餐回家。那是一种非常稳定的获取食物的方式，而且没有任何迷信行为。现在他们做这件事是因为他们知道这样做有效，而且他们知道这能给他们带来第二天所需的卡路里和食物。当同样的人去捕鲨鱼时，
it was a dramatically different experience in terms of supernatural beliefs. There was a magic man of the village who instituted all sorts of taboos on whether, you know, you couldn't sing, you couldn't have sex, you couldn't whistle, you couldn't have sex, you couldn't whistle, you had to wear certain clothing. And then when it was shark hunting day. Would you normally have sex while you were shark hunting? Like does that need to be?
在超自然信仰方面，这是一种截然不同的体验。村里有一个魔法师，他制定了各种各样的禁忌，关于，你知道，你不能唱歌，你不能发生性关系，你不能吹口哨，你不能发生性关系，你不能吹口哨，你必须穿特定的衣服。然后当那是鲨鱼狩猎日的时候。你通常会在捕鲨鱼的时候发生性关系吗？就像那需要吗？
Well, like I'm talking about, like, good question, John. I'm glad you raised that. No, the answer is no. This is like the two months leading up to shark hunting season. Yeah, I don't need to presume, you know, how you hunt sharks or kink shame. You've been doing it all wrong. Yeah. Now when I have to shark, it's it's it's pretty steamy. You know, the jaws. Oh my god. They go out in these boats on the open ocean in a dangerous spot weather-wise and they
嗯，就像我在说，好问题，约翰。我很高兴你提到了这一点。不，答案是否定的。这是在鲨鱼狩猎季节开始前的两个月。是的，我不需要推测，你知道，你是如何捕鲨鱼的，或者羞辱你的癖好。你一直都做错了。是的。现在当我不得不捕鲨鱼时，它，它，它相当刺激。你知道，大白鲨。哦，天哪。他们乘着这些船在开阔的海洋中，在一个天气危险的地方，他们
have these sort of like sticks with shells strung along the sticks and they shake those sticks underwater and it mimics the sound of a shoal of fish jumping in and out of the water. And then when the shark comes to that sound, they bash in the shark's head with like a piece of like stove wood essentially. And that is not at all a sure thing, right? That's a very chaotic endeavor without a lot of hope of success. And because it's such a, a sort of like chaotic, uncertain area of their lives, they attach all sorts of superstitions because they didn't have any other sort of way to, to have the confidence of control that they had when they were fishing in the coral reefs.
有这些，就像棍子上串着贝壳，他们在水下摇动那些棍子，它模仿了一群鱼在水中跳进跳出的声音。然后当鲨鱼被那个声音吸引过来时，他们用像木柴一样的东西猛击鲨鱼的头。那根本不是一件确定的事情，对吧？那是一个非常混乱的努力，没有多少成功的希望。而且因为它是一个，某种，混乱的、不确定的生活领域，他们附加了各种各样的迷信，因为他们没有其他任何方式来，来获得他们在珊瑚礁捕鱼时所拥有的那种控制的信心。
And so when a society is more chaotic, when we feel like we have less control over our lives, you know, certainly we feel like we have less control over our lives, certainly we're going to be more prone to turning to supernatural explanations for things. Maybe we can compartmentalize where we can ask an astrologer about how to cope with grief, but we can still ask an accountant to do our finances. But maybe we can still ask an accountant to do our finances, but maybe we can't you know, maybe we're just you know a couple generations away from Asking our astrologer to do our finances
所以当一个社会更加混乱时，当我们觉得我们对自己的生活控制力更弱时，你知道，当然我们觉得我们对自己的生活控制力更弱，当然我们就会更容易转向超自然的解释。也许我们可以把事情分门别类，我们可以问占星家如何应对悲伤，但我们仍然可以请会计师来处理我们的财务。但也许我们仍然可以请会计师来处理我们的财务，但也许我们不能，你知道，也许我们只是，你知道，离请我们的占星家来处理我们的财务还有几代人的距离
uh I think a lot of when I was saying that I think we're approaching something with institutional decline that looks kind of like the 70s is Like anytime an empire star is waning You see a rise in a belief in magic. And that's why I get so frustrated with people where I'm like, even if you believe this, you want the same political outcome I want,
嗯，我想当我那样说的时候，我想我们正在接近某种制度衰落，看起来有点像70年代，就像任何帝国开始衰落时，你都会看到对魔法的信仰上升。这就是为什么我对人们感到如此沮丧，我说，即使你相信这一点，你也想要和我一样的政治结果，
if you press this button, it does this. Like it just, it does. And like when you look at, because, and it makes sense because like when the Edward Endre has like a cool diagram and ego and archetype where he's talking about the thing where the institution is containing the archetypes Versus where the unconscious is speaking directly to people and the intuition looks a lot like, you know schizophrenia but there's like this you go back to like Rome and when they're the
如果你按下这个按钮，它就会做这个。就像它只是，它确实如此。而且就像当你观察时，因为，这很有道理，因为就像当爱德华·恩丁格（Edward Edinger）在《自我与原型》（Ego and Archetype）中有一个很酷的图表，他在谈论机构包含原型的那个东西，相对于无意识直接对人们说话的地方，而直觉看起来很像，你知道精神分裂症，但就像这个，你回到像罗马那样的时候，当他们
Gaul is getting paraded through the streets with elephants and they they're like, the empire reflects your ego. Your personal power is the nation, or the religious cult is an extension of your personal power, so you have power and certainty. People feel okay, or okay, well, the empire's not doing so hot, but we're gonna pay for these gladiatory games, go watch football, and your team's gonna win, and you're gonna get, it's a reflection of my ego.
高卢人带着大象在街上游行，他们就像，帝国反映了你的自我。你的个人力量就是国家，或者宗教崇拜是你个人力量的延伸，所以你有力量和确定性。人们感觉还好，或者好吧，帝国表现得不太好，但我们要为这些角斗士比赛买单，去看足球，你的球队会赢，你会得到，这是我自我的反映。
When you say All the all the political options are bad. You're not gonna get what you want Yeah, you can go vote but it's the ending of Mass Effect 3 then what happens is People go inward to find a source of certainty and and and sometimes with interesting results I mean, I don't think that process is entirely bad. But like yeah when you say interesting results. I mean, I don't think that process is entirely bad. But like, yeah, when you say, left or right, whatever you want, the political options are terrible, and you're not going to get what you want, and the empire doesn't do anything that you want. And yeah, we have these huge group of issues that are bipartisan, that everyone wants. Neither political party will touch them. What you get is 60% of your population believing in magic every
当你说明明所有的政治选择都很糟糕。你不会得到你想要的。是的，你可以去投票，但那是《质量效应3》的结局，然后发生的事情是人们向内寻找确定性的来源，而且有时会有有趣的结果。我的意思是，我不认为那个过程完全是坏的。但是就像，是的，当你说明明左派或右派，随你便，政治选择很糟糕，你不会得到你想要的，而且帝国不做任何你想要的事情。而且是的，我们有这些巨大的群体问题，是两党制的，每个人都想要的。没有政党会触及它们。你得到的是60%的人口相信魔法，每次
time. That's why Mithraic cults exploded in Rome. Like, if you do that, that's what you get. And there's people that want to be like, well, I go on to Wikipedia and I cite my sources and I have a thing where you can check the meme for accuracy. It doesn't matter. If you continue to have a political stagnation like we're doing, what you get is this, you know? and, and you, you could say you don't like that, but not accepting that it's just a refusal to accept the way the world works on its own terms. You know, this pretend it's absolutely true. And whether we chalk that instability up to, you know, hyper partisanship or late stage capitalism, or just sort of like societal decay or the internet or whatever it is, you're
都是这样。这就是为什么密特拉教在罗马爆炸式增长。就像，如果你那样做，那就是你得到的。而且有些人想表现得像，嗯，我上维基百科，我引用我的来源，我有一个可以检查模因准确性的东西。没关系。如果你继续像我们现在这样进行政治停滞，你得到的就是这个，你知道？而且，而且你，你可以说你不喜欢那样，但不接受它只是拒绝接受世界按其自身条款运作的方式。你知道，这假装它是绝对真实的。无论我们将这种不稳定归因于，你知道，超级党派之争，还是晚期资本主义，或者只是某种社会衰落，还是互联网，或者其他什么，你
absolutely right that it seems inevitable that these beliefs are going to be spiking around now. And it's really, really important that we figure out ways to cope with and overcome that and still have faith in one another and in our collective actions. Because that's really what's sort of like its sake here is the belief in a shared reality. Yeah. Right? Yeah. If your normal beliefs that prize the individual experience over a shared reality, whether
绝对正确，这些信仰在现在左右激增似乎是不可避免的。我们必须找到方法来应对和克服这一点，并仍然对彼此以及我们的集体行动保持信心，这真的非常非常重要。因为这才是这里真正处于危险之中的东西，即对共享现实的信仰。是的。对吧？是的。如果你的正常信仰将个人体验置于共享现实之上，无论
that shared reality is, you know, the dogma of a church or the outcome of a scientific study, you know, the facts, then you really have a radically different society that may not be able to take care of its people in the same way that we have right now. And if that's the way we're going, we got to bridge that gap and make sure that that's a positive change in society and not just this sort of like degradation and collapse
那个共享现实是，你知道，教会的教条还是科学研究的结果，你知道，事实，那么你确实拥有一个截然不同的社会，它可能无法像我们现在这样照顾它的人民。如果这就是我们要走的路，我们必须弥合那个差距，并确保那是社会的一个积极变化，而不仅仅是这种某种退化和崩溃
like has happened in the past as you point out to. Well, I mean, I think, you know, both political parties don't really want to do the things that I mean, to a certain extent, some elements I think in the Republicans do it like a lot of the Democrats, people are like, we've seen you get elected, we've seen you have a supermajority, we've seen you control three branches of government. And then you were like, Oh, well, somehow mcconnell's stopping me I don't know. I have to wait till 100% of everyone agrees with me to do anything and When you do that You know people quit believing you and you know when people can see not even the weird coincidences and deep esoteric
就像过去发生的那样，正如你指出的那样。嗯，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，两个政党都不太想做那些事情，我的意思是，在某种程度上，我认为共和党中的一些元素会这样做，就像很多民主党人一样，人们会说，我们看到你当选了，我们看到你拥有绝对多数，我们看到你控制了政府的三个分支。然后你就说，哦，好吧，不知何故麦康奈尔在阻止我，我不知道。我必须等到100%的人都同意我才能做任何事情，当你这样做时，你知道人们就不再相信你了，而且你知道当人们能看到甚至不是那些奇怪的巧合和深奥的
Whatever, I mean when people can just see okay the Panama paper things happen and the official story does not make sense. The people you're punishing are not even the ones when the Epstein thing happens. I mean, those, and no one will touch these things. You know, when just every 15 years we say, oh, oops, the CIA did something really bad but no one was punished and we promise we won't do it again
无论如何，我的意思是当人们能看到，好吧，巴拿马文件的事情发生了，官方说法说不通。你惩罚的人甚至不是那些，当爱泼斯坦事件发生时。我的意思是，那些，没有人会触及这些事情。你知道，当每15年我们说，哦，哎呀，中央情报局做了一些非常糟糕的事情，但没有人受到惩罚，我们保证我们不会再这样做
but no one was held accountable and we'll do this 12 years later. You know, since when you continue to do that, you know, what do you expect to happen? And when you have neither political party will do anything, I think that, and I'm not trying to make a political point, I'm just trying to make a psychology one that like, you're feeding all of these things
但没有人被追究责任，我们会在12年后再次这样做。你知道，既然你继续这样做，你知道，你期望发生什么？而且当你没有任何政党会做任何事情时，我认为，而且我不是想发表政治观点，我只是想发表一个心理学观点，即，你正在助长所有这些事情
that are ripping these institutions down that you claim to love based on your own avoidance of those issues and those hard problems. And I think that you look at that really honestly at the end of this one. It seems like that we've cut out so many exceptions to transparency in the name of national security or the name of sort of like shielding medical practitioners from consequences and all that sort of thing. Like, you know, those are good goals, I suppose, to maintain national security and to allow a practitioner to- Did it work? Is the world better? I mean, Noam Chomsky has got a pretty good line in the end of one of his books about like, if you look at the war in Iraq and you look at everything
那些正在摧毁你声称热爱的机构的人，正是基于你对这些议题和难题的逃避。我认为在这一集结束时，你会非常诚实地审视这一点。似乎我们以国家安全或保护医疗从业者免受后果等名义，为透明度设置了太多的例外。比如，你知道，我认为维护国家安全和允许从业者……这奏效了吗？世界变得更好了吗？我的意思是，诺姆·乔姆斯基在他的一本书结尾有一句很好的话，大意是，如果你看看伊拉克战争，看看所有的一切
that we did after 9 11, assume we did nothing and we took this money and we spent it on anything else. Yeah, lighting it on fire may have been better than what we did. Yeah. Yeah. The effects we're dealing with now and will be over the next 25 years from that foreign policy experiment. But there's no accountability. John Bolton is back in the White House for a minute
我们在911之后所做的一切，假设我们什么都没做，而是把这些钱花在其他任何事情上。是的，把钱烧掉可能都比我们所做的要好。是的。是的。我们现在正在处理的，以及未来25年内将要面对的，都是那场外交政策实验的后果。但没有任何问责制。约翰·博尔顿又回到了白宫，待了一会儿
until someone else is. It's like, can we take some of that hyperlogic and objectivity that we claim to do and maybe look at people who have been wrong about foreign policy every time they've opened their mouth for 80 years and get them out of the Senate. Can we do that? Right, right, right. Absolutely. And we defend them because there's no one else until they're so old, they have dementia. And so it's mean to criticize them, but they still have to
直到被别人取代。这就像，我们能否运用我们声称拥有的那种超逻辑和客观性，去审视那些80年来每次开口都在外交政策上犯错的人，并把他们赶出参议院？我们能做到吗？对，对，对。绝对可以。我们为他们辩护，因为没有其他人选，直到他们老到患上痴呆症。所以批评他们显得很刻薄，但他们仍然必须
be wielding the keys to nuclear missiles. I mean, what is that system? And how do you expect anybody to go into a hospital and be like, yeah, this makes sense. I believe in authority and stuff. It's it's money in politics. It's special interests. It's it's yeah, it's a, and one of the things that's so frustrating about it is that every time there's sort of like a surge of, you know, what I'll call progressive, progressivism, but because I am a progressive, is, you know, every advancement of worker rights, say, is sort of like, grappled with by the capitalistic powers that be, and they just evolve new systems. And so every time there's an advance, we make the system tougher and the game gets harder to beat. And it takes so much collective action to achieve anything for members of the public.
掌握核导弹的钥匙。我的意思是，那是什么样的制度？你指望谁走进医院时会说，是的，这很有道理。我相信权威之类的东西。这是金钱政治。这是特殊利益集团。是的，这确实是……最令人沮丧的事情之一是，每当出现某种所谓的进步主义浪潮时——因为我本人就是个进步主义者——每一项工人权利的进步，都会被现有的资本主义势力所阻挠，他们只是进化出了新的系统。所以每一次进步，我们都会让系统变得更严苛，游戏变得更难赢。而要为公众争取任何利益，都需要付出巨大的集体行动。
And the power structure just sort of like adapts and evolved. You know, I did you were you a comic book fan? I've read some yeah. All right. I was really into like the Marvel comics for a while when I was a teen and there was like this group called the West Coast Avengers they had Hawkeye and some of the others and Avengers. They had Hawkeye and some of the others. And they got into this fight against this robot creature or whatever. They would go out and the individuals on the team would defeat it, but every time it got defeated, it just reprogrammed to accommodate that flaw that had led to that loss. that flaw that had led to that loss. And that's sort of like what the capitalistic
而权力结构只是在适应和进化。你知道，你以前是漫画迷吗？我读过一些，是的。好吧。我十几岁的时候有一段时间非常迷漫威漫画，当时有一个叫“西海岸复仇者”的组织，里面有鹰眼和其他一些人。他们和那个机器人生物之类的东西打了一架。他们会出击，团队里的个人会击败它，但每次它被击败，它就会重新编程以适应导致失败的那个缺陷。而这正是资本主义
powers are that run the world. And it's really dispiriting. And, you know, it really does feel like they're being very well served by the current chaos. They're kind of immune to protests at this point. I mean, protests were a scary thing in the 70s. I don't know that they are anymore. You know? Yeah. Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. You know? Yeah. Yeah.
统治世界的势力所做的。这真的很令人沮丧。而且，你知道，这确实让人感觉他们从当前的混乱中获益良多。他们现在对抗议几乎免疫了。我的意思是，抗议在70年代是一件可怕的事情。我不知道现在还是不是这样。你知道吗？是的，是的，我认为这绝对是真的。你知道吗？是的，是的。
I think that's absolutely true. A public reaction is just kind of built into the system and the, the, the mathematics to be accounted for in a way where it changes, uh, take the option for changes taken away from you, which is, you know, what we're talking about few feeds, a lot of these problems. People feel that whether or not they consciously are aware of it, they, they feel it and that energy goes somewhere. They're just so insulated and you know, Starbucks puts a lot more thought into what symbols
我认为这绝对是真的。公众的反应只是被内置到了系统中，而那些需要被考量的数学计算方式，使得改变的选项被剥夺了，这也就是我们所说的，助长了许多这些问题。人们无论是否有意识地察觉到，他们都能感觉到，而那种能量会流向某处。他们被保护得太好了，你知道，星巴克在咖啡杯上放什么符号所花的心思
they're going to put on their coffee cup than they do on their coffee. They have to pay anyone a fair wage because the coffee cup symbology will motivate people and the fair wage will not you know You'll not see people turning out on the streets in anger or the fact that You know workers aren't getting paid a livable wage say and not to pick on Starbucks specifically, but You know choose choose your company. Well, I think what you're talking about at the end what you're implying I think is incentive structures. I mean people want to like cancel this or get mad at one company I mean I remember there was like a huge thing where
比在咖啡本身上花的心思多得多。他们不必给任何人支付公平的工资，因为咖啡杯上的符号就能激励人们，而公平的工资却不能。你知道，你不会看到人们因为工人们没有得到维持生计的工资而愤怒地走上街头，这并不是专门针对星巴克，但你知道，选哪家公司都一样。嗯，我想你最后所说的，你所暗示的，我认为是激励结构。我的意思是，人们想要抵制这个或对某家公司感到愤怒，我记得当时有一件大事，就是
People were angry with Walmart for doing something and I was like was the thing legal they're like, yeah But stop Walmart and I was like, yeah Maybe you put enough pressure on Walmart to do it a different way But everyone else will make it illegal if you don't want them to do it I mean, there's a whole thing where people are like, oh subway puts a chemical that's allowed to make it illegal if you don't want them to do it. I mean, there's a whole thing where people are like, oh, Subway puts a chemical that's allowed to, that is used to make yoga mats and the bread.
人们对沃尔玛做某事感到愤怒，我就问，那件事合法吗？他们说，是的，但要抵制沃尔玛。我说，是的，也许你可以给沃尔玛施加足够的压力让它换种方式做，但如果你不希望他们做，其他人也会让它合法化。我的意思是，有一整件事是人们说，哦，赛百味添加了一种化学物质，被允许用来制作瑜伽垫，也用在面包里。
And in Europe, you can't even feed this to mice in a lab, but we feed it to kids here. And so Subway is bad. And it's like, is it legal to put that chemical in food? Why? If the incentive structure allows it and incentivizes you to do it, most people will do it. But we want to make personal accountability work like for corporations or something in this weird way where it's like
而在欧洲，这东西甚至不能喂给实验室的老鼠，但我们却喂给这里的孩子。所以赛百味很糟糕。这就好比，在食物中添加那种化学物质合法吗？为什么？如果激励结构允许并鼓励你这样做，大多数人都会这样做。但我们却想以这种奇怪的方式让企业承担个人责任，就好像
You can't cancel Halliburton in the same way you can cancel Neil Gaiman, you know, you you have to say Go out and do this speaking of comic books. Yeah Yeah, I I think that Someone to the stuff that you'd say is is really interesting. You also speak truth to power and one important point Circus peanuts are terrible. I don't think since banana. What's there's been a worse candy Who is buying them Talk about things that ought to be illegal. They're always in the bag where if you buy two, you get it for like nine cents cheaper or something.
你不能像抵制尼尔·盖曼那样抵制哈里伯顿，你知道，你必须说……去吧，做这件事。说到漫画书。是的，是的，我认为你所说的一些事情真的很有趣。你也敢于对权力说真话，有一个重要的观点：马戏团花生糖太难吃了。我不认为自香蕉味之后还有比这更糟糕的糖果。谁会买它们？谈谈那些本该被禁止的东西。它们总是在那种买两袋就能便宜九美分之类的促销里。
I'd like one circus peanut, please. OK, but for four dollars less, you can have all of these circus peanuts. You can have a bat of them. OK, I guess I got to buy the best. Yeah, we give people a little sample, too, because there's one place where you mentioned me in the book, which is the circus. have all of these circus peanuts you can have a bat of them okay I guess I gotta buy the bat yeah we'll give people a little sample too because there's one place where you mentioned me in the book which I appreciate so just go ahead and get to that um here we go please do this is this is not my voice this is Matt's voice it's read in right in his voice um my investigation led me to
我想要一个马戏团花生糖，谢谢。好的，但少花四美元，你就可以拥有所有这些马戏团花生糖。你可以拥有一大袋。好吧，我想我得买那一袋。是的，我们也会给人们一点样本，因为书里有一个地方你提到了我，我很感激，所以直接讲到那儿吧，嗯，开始了，请这样做，这不是我的声音，这是马特的录音，用他的声音读的……我的调查引导我到了
Alabama where I met a shoeless dullard of a social worker shirtless grubby barbecue grease smeared overalls. His dull sad eyes peered out beneath the brim of a loosely woven straw hat. His reptile like tongue licked gnats and beads of perspiration from his patchy mustache, delicately savoring each indiscriminately as if they were the sweetest ambrosia. So this is beautiful prose. I mean, that's like looking into a mirror. I don't know how you-
阿拉巴马州，在那里我遇到了一个没穿鞋的笨拙社工，他没穿衬衫，邋里邋遢，工装裤上沾满了烧烤油渍。他那呆滞悲伤的眼睛从一顶编织松散的草帽檐下窥视着。他那像爬行动物一样的舌头舔着他那斑驳胡须上的小虫和汗珠，优雅地品味着每一滴，仿佛它们是世间最甜美的仙馔密酒。所以，这是优美的散文。我的意思是，这就像照镜子一样。我不知道你是怎么……
Thank you. That was actually the first draft. I'm so surprised that that made sense. So that is not where actually Matt's writing. If you want to read it, you should buy the book on Amazon. Is there a place where people can buy it that is more beneficial to you? Well, no, I do get asked that and I always appreciate the question, but the answer is just no, you
谢谢。那其实是初稿。我很惊讶它竟然读得通。所以那其实不是马特写的内容。如果你想读，你应该在亚马逊上买这本书。有没有什么地方买对你更有利？嗯，不，我确实常被问到这个问题，我总是很感激这个提问，但答案就是没有，你
know, get it from your library. You know, like I don't care. What is good for me is people reading it and liking it and talking about it to friends and family and sort of like building that culture of appreciation for it. And that is that is money in my pocket at the end of the day. And it also makes me feel very good. So if you if you have, you know, 30 bucks, go buy the hardcover. If you don't get it from the library, go steal it out of Joel's office. Oh yeah, yeah, because you had what two, three copies of If It Walks Like A Quack disappeared from the waiting room. I love the idea of like a bit about somebody that's obsessed with evidence-based practice in medicine and also a thief.
知道，从图书馆借吧。你知道，我不在乎。对我来说好的是人们读它、喜欢它，并向朋友和家人谈论它，从而建立起一种欣赏它的文化。归根结底，那才是我的收入。而且这也会让我感觉非常好。所以如果你有30美元，去买精装本。如果没有，就从图书馆借，或者去乔尔的办公室偷一本。哦，是的，是的，因为你的《如果它走起来像个庸医》有两三本从候诊室消失了。我喜欢那种关于一个痴迷于循证医学同时又是个小偷的人的段子。
and also a thief. Yeah, and Matt's first two books, so Libertarian Walks Into a Bear. I mean, there's a great, if you want a sample of that one, there's a great write up in, I think, the Atlantic or something. What is it? And this is the New Republic. The New Republic.
同时也是个小偷。是的，马特的前两本书，比如《自由意志主义者走进一只熊》。我的意思是，如果你想看那本的样本，大西洋月刊之类的杂志上有一篇很棒的报道。是什么来着？是《新共和》。《新共和》。
Yeah. That's a great preview of that one. It's a great book. And it walks like a quack. It's a really interesting kind of walk through The scientific method and the ways that people grift in health care and this one's fantastic. I think goes live is my favorite Just yeah, and there's a lot of places where you just let this stuff be as funny as it is what with in a loving way And it's just it's really sweet. It's touching dills into all of these questions about our society.
是的。那是那本书很棒的预告。那是一本好书。《如果它走起来像个庸医》是对科学方法以及人们在医疗保健领域行骗方式的一次非常有趣的剖析，而这一本太棒了。我认为《Go Live》是我最喜欢的。是的，有很多地方你只是让这些内容保持它原本的幽默感，以一种充满爱意的方式。这真的很甜，很感人，深入探讨了我们社会的所有这些问题。
It's beautiful. If nothing else, you learn so much about the inner workings of a paranormal-themed organization. Everything from a psychomantium to a psychic fair to a ghost hunt. There's just all sorts of interesting settings and devices in the narrative that lend themselves to a really fun experience, I think, in the reading. So thank you, Joel, so much for saying such kind things about the book.
这很美。至少，你可以学到很多关于超自然主题组织内部运作的知识。从通灵室到通灵博览会，再到捉鬼活动。叙事中有很多各种各样有趣的场景和装置，我认为这让阅读体验变得非常有趣。所以，乔尔，非常感谢你对这本书说了这么多好话。
And I'm really looking forward to being able to see more people read it and and hopefully share your enjoyment of it Why I really appreciate you coming on I want to be respectful of your time if there's anything that because I know you're an hour ahead of me So it's probably late there and we but if if there's anything that you want to talk about or things we can do as Trying to structure the conversation so there were certain clips I could cut around to get the sciency crowd and then a funny joke for my Instagram and like different things together
我真的很期待看到更多人阅读它，并希望分享你们对它的喜爱。我真的很感谢你来参加节目，我想尊重你的时间，因为我知道你比我早一个小时，所以那边可能很晚了，但是如果有什么你想谈的，或者我们可以做的事情，因为我试图构建对话，这样我就可以剪辑出一些片段来吸引科学爱好者，然后为我的Instagram准备一个有趣的笑话，把不同的东西放在一起
But if there's anything you want to go on about you know I'm happy to continue and then put that I can put that in you know earlier in the interview or anything Let me think for just a second if I want to take advantage of that it is it is getting Pretty late here, but sorry. I'm sorry that our no no no it's not on you at all I'm looking at everything left on my like notes from the book And they're either pretty abstract or they're like jokes about echo the dolphin being like RFKs dreams and things like that Well yeah, I guess I think the one thing that I'll say is that I do think our current environment of institutional distrust and sort of like anti-institutionalism is maybe the most pressing political issue of our time. Yeah. It is at the root of everything that's wrong with America and all of our institutions
但如果你有什么想继续聊的，你知道，我很乐意继续，然后我可以把它放在采访的前面或者其他地方。让我思考一下，如果我想利用这个机会的话，这里确实已经很晚了，但是抱歉。我很抱歉我们的……不，不，不，这完全不怪你。我正在看我笔记里剩下的所有关于这本书的内容。它们要么相当抽象，要么就是像“海豚艾可”是小肯尼迪的梦想之类的笑话。好吧，是的，我想我要说的唯一一件事是，我确实认为我们当前这种机构不信任和某种反机构主义的环境，可能是我们这个时代最紧迫的政治问题。是的。它是美国所有问题以及我们所有机构问题的根源
and talking heads that are trying to address the idea of institutional distrust by debunking conspiracy theories and talking about science literacy and all that, they're all completely off base. They've identified the problem, but they haven't identified the solution. And I think that folks who read the book will get a different perspective into how you can thwart a conspiracy theory by understanding the conspiracy theorists behind it. And you can-
而那些试图通过揭穿阴谋论、谈论科学素养等来解决机构不信任问题的名嘴们，他们完全找错了方向。他们发现了问题，但没有找到解决方案。我认为读过这本书的人会得到一个不同的视角，了解如何通过理解阴谋论者背后的心理来挫败阴谋论。而且你可以……
And I would say the emotion under the conspiracy theory and the material need that is fueling that emotion. you know, if you provide healthcare, if you provide these things, you know, what you're going to get what you say you want, you know, so let's go ahead and separate the people who say they want it and the people who actually want it, you know, politically. Yeah, yeah, absolutely, absolutely. And, and, and how we can sort of like, you know, co-opt might be choosing too strong a word, but how you can harness the energy behind this very vibrant culture that encompasses a large swath of America and had that work for the public good instead of its current harmful expressions. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I really appreciate your time. It's wonderful to speak with you. Hunt for ghosts inside our hearts cause we'll never give up Wishing that we live on, baby we live on
而且我会说，阴谋论背后的情绪以及推动这种情绪的物质需求。你知道，如果你提供医疗保健，如果你提供这些东西，你知道，你会得到你想要的东西，你知道，所以让我们把那些说他们想要它的人和那些真正想要它的人在政治上区分开来。是的，是的，绝对，绝对。以及我们如何能够，你知道，联合——也许用这个词太强烈了——但你如何能够利用这种充满活力的文化背后的能量，这种文化涵盖了美国的一大片区域，并让它为公共利益服务，而不是它目前那种有害的表达方式。是的，是的。好吧，我真的很感谢你的时间。和你交谈真是太棒了。在我们的心中寻找鬼魂，因为我们永远不会放弃，希望我们能活下去，宝贝，我们活下去
In our song, our haunted song There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的歌里，我们闹鬼的歌里。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。